hello and welcome back to our Channel
I'm Amad and today we have got an
exciting topic to dive into cyber
security for beginners whether you are
new to the world of cyber security or
just looking to enhance your Online
safety this video is perfect for you
cyber security is crucial in today's
digital world with the increasing number
of online threats it's a ential to learn
the basics of protecting your data
privacy and online identity in this
video we'll break down what cyber
security is why it matters and how you
can get started on your journey to
becoming a cyber security s individual
we'll cover essential topics like
encryption passwords and tips for safe
online practices and by the end of this
video you will have a solid
understanding of how to protect yourself
in the digital realm but before we get
started if you want to become a cyber
security expert and gain handsome salary
packages look at a wide range of cyber
security courses offered by simply learn
and that is in collaboration with top
universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
programs you will gain expertise in
skills like idas firewalls and honey
ports Network packet analysis security
and risk management identity and access
management software development security
pren back TOs and counter measures
mobile and web Technologies and there's
much more on the list with handson
experience in tools you will catch the
eye of top recruiters so what are you
waiting for hurry up and enroll now and
a year of experience is prefer to enroll
in these courses you can find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below and pin comment and make sure to
subscribe to our Channel hit that
notification Bell and give this video a
thumbs up if you are excited to learn
about cyber security also let us know in
the comments below what motivated you to
learn about cyber security all right now
that you are all set let's jump into the
exciting world of cyber security she
often shops from www. shoppingcart
doccom she has her information like
email ID address and credit card details
saved on the website to enable a faster
and hassle-free shopping
experience the required information is
stored in a server one day Anne received
an email which stated her eligibility
for a special discount voucher from
shopping cart.com in order to receive
the coupon code she was asked to fill in
her shopping cart.com account
credentials this didn't seem fishy to
her at the time as she thought it was
just an account verification step little
did she realize the danger she would be
facing she was knocked off her feet when
a substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account how do you think this
happened when well yes the email she
received was fake ANS shopping cart.com
account witnessed unauthorized access
from a third party this type of attack
is known as a Cyber attack and the
person who carries it out is called a
hacker could Ann have prevented this
attack indeed she could have with the
help of cyber security cyber security
involves techniques that help in
securing various digital components
networks data and computer systems from
authorized digital access there are
multiple ways to implement cyber
security depending on the kind of
network you are connected to and the
type of cyber attacks you are prone to
so let's take a look at the various
cyber attacks that Anne could have been
exposed to one of the most common types
of cyber attacks is a malware attack
like Trojan adwar and spyware to name a
few had Anne downloaded any suspicious
attachments online her system could have
gotten corrupted by C certain malicious
viruses embedded within the attachments
next is a fishing attack the type of
Cyber attack which an experienced here
the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
legitimate Source this is done to
install malware or to steal sensitive
data like credit card information and
login
credentials another type of attack is
the man in the middle attack here the
hacker gains access to the information
path between ANS device and the website
server the Hacker's computer takes over
Ann's IP address by doing so the
communication line between an and the
website is secretly intercepted this
commonly happens with unsecured Wi-Fi
networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system here Ann's
password could have been cracked by
using either common passwords or trying
all possible alphabetical combinations
to prevent future cyber attacks and
sought to implement a few cyber security
practices first she installed a firewall
as the name suggests it is a virtual
wall between Ann's computer and the
internet firewalls filter the incoming
and outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
Hardware reinforcements secondly an
implemented honey pots just like how
flowers attract bees dummy computer
systems called honeypots are used to
attract ATT attackers these systems are
made to look vulnerable in order to
deceive attackers and this in turn
defends the real system in addition to
these she also decided to use unique
alpha numeric passwords antivirus
software and started avoiding males from
unknown Cinders that was Ann's story
cyber attacks are not just confined to
individuals but also to public and
private organizations the cyber attacks
carried out in such places are more
deadly and they result in colossal
losses motives of such attacks are many
starting from tampering with crucial
data to monetary gains let's have a look
at a few of the cyber attacks that
companies are subjected to various
public sector organizations and large
corporations face the advanced
persistent threat a in this form of
attack hackers gain access to networks
for a prolonged period in order to
continuously gain confidential
information companies also Witness the
denial of service attack where networks
are flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack when a hacker
manipulates a standard SQL query in a
database driven website it is known as a
SQL injection attack by doing so hackers
can view edit and delete tables from
databases amidst a plethora of cyber
attacks it is indeed a challenge for
organizations with several networks and
servers to ensure complete Security this
is not an easy task and to help with
this cyber Security Professionals are
hired to work on identifying cyber
threats and securing a company's Network
there are multiple job roles in the
field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored such professionals try to exp a
networks vulnerabilities just like how
hacker would do but only to identify
those vulnerabilities and resolve them
for protection against an actual Cyber
attack but if you are looking to design
robust security structures then the role
of a security architect is more apt a
chief information security officer ciso
plays a crucial role in Enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization today's digital age cyber
security is more critical than ever with
the ever evolving threat landscape
ethical hackers play a pivotal role in
safeguarding our digital world let's
dive into the facts and figures that
make this topic not just interesting but
essential so moving to the introduction
cyber crime is expected to cost the
world do 10.5 trillion annually by 2025
making it one of the most lucrative
criminal activities in history the
demand for ethical hacking is
skyrocketing with 3.5 million unfilled
cyber security jobs and the average
salary of a certain ifed ethical hacker
in the United States is approximately
$97,000 per year and it's consistently
one of the highest paying it
certifications now let's explore the
road map that will guide you to become
an ethical hacker in 2024 and before
that if you are an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learn postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
in collaboration with EC Council should
be your right choice the course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and this course requires
just a bachelor's degree with a 50%
average and no prior programming
experience and one plus year of book
experience is preferred and for more
details you can use the link mentioned
in the description box below and if
these are the types of videos you would
like to watch then hit the Subscribe
button like and press on the Bell icon
to never miss on future content so stay
tuned with us until the end of this
video and don't forget to register your
opinion in the comment section below now
starting with what is ethical hacking
ethical hacking often referred to as
whad hacking or penetration testing is a
cyber security practice in which
individuals known as ethical hackers or
penetration testers legally and
responsibly attempt to uncover
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in
computer systems networks applications
and other digital infrastructure the
primary goal of ethical hacking is to
identify and resolve security flows
before malicious hackers can exploit
them and now we'll see the essential
skills for ethical hacker certainly hear
a list of essential skills for an
ethical hacker starting with strong
understanding of networking that is
ethical hackers need to have a deep
understanding of networking protocols
how data travels across networks and the
vulnerabilities associated with
different network configurations number
two programming and scripting
Proficiency in programming languages
like python C C++ and scripting
languages is crucial for writing custom
exploit and tools and the next is cyber
security fundamentals a solid grasp of
basic cyber security Concepts including
threats vulnerabilities risk management
and security principles is fundamental
now coming to next that is operating
system familiarity with various
operating systems including Windows
Linux and Unix is essential for
understanding their vulnerabilities and
security configurations then comes the
web application security knowledge of
web Technologies web application
vulnerabilities such as equal injection
crite scripting and security best
practices for web development and then
comes the penetration testing tools
Proficiency in tools like Metasploit
nmap wire shock bub suit and other
penetration testing tools used to assess
system
vulnerabilities and then we have
cryptography understanding of encryption
decryption cryptographic algorithms and
their role in securing data and then
there is wireless security expertise in
wireless network security including
Wi-Fi encryption protocols and
vulnerabilities and then we have
security compliance and standards
knowledge of security standards and
compliance regulations such as PCI DSS
HIPAA and gdpr and the next skill is
incident response being prepared to
handle security incidents and breaches
effectively including forensics and
Analysis understanding of social
engineering tactics used by attackers to
manipulate individuals into revealing
confidential information and then comes
ethical mindset an ethical hacker must
adhere to a strong code of ethics and
prioritize responsible disclosure when
vulnerabilities are found and now we'll
move to ethical hacker road map 2024
we'll start with step one that is build
a strong Foundation Building a strong
Foundation is crucial in the journey to
become an ethical hacker start with a
deep understanding of computer science
mastering the basics of Hardware
software and networks familiarize
yourself with operating systems and
their functionalities entry-level
certifications like coma A+ and network
plus are your Stepping Stones ensuring
you grasp The Core Concepts of ID a
strong Foundation forms the Bedrock upon
which you will build your ethical
hacking skills and knowledge and then
comes step two learn programming
learning programming is a gateway to
unlocking Endless Possibilities in the
Digital World start by understanding the
basics of coding logic and syntax
explore languages like python known for
its Simplicity or JavaScript for web
development practice regly work on real
projects and seek online tutorials and
courses Embrace problem solving and
debugging and gradually you will Master
the art of programming opening doors to
a world of software development and
Innovation now moving to the step three
that is understand cyber security Basics
understand cyber security Basics is
crucial for any aspiring ethical hacker
it involves comprehending the core
principles of protecting digital systems
and data key Concepts include
identifying threats vulnerabilities and
the importance of risk management
certification programs like com Security
Plus can provide an entry point into
this realm these Basics form the
foundation for ethical hacking enabling
individuals to recognize and combat
security weaknesses making the digital
world safer and then comes the step four
that is dive into ethical hacking dive
into ethical hacking is a critical step
on the journey to becoming a skilled
ethical hacker during this phase you
will focus on horning your penetration
testing skills and mastering the art of
ethical hacking the certified ethical
hacker certification will be your
companion providing you with the
knowledge and tools to identify
vulnerabilities and secure systems you
will explore real world scenarios test
networks and learn to think like a
hacker while maintaining ethical
standards this stage prepares you to
safeguard digital Landscapes effectively
and then comes step five that is
continue learning continuing learning in
ethical hacking is essential the cyber
security landscape evolves rapidly so
staying up to date is a must explore
Advanced certifications like cissp and
certified ethical hacker C to deepen
your knowledge follow industry news
blogs and research to remain informed
about emerging threats join ethical
hacking communities attend conferences
and engage in ongoing practice to hor
your skills remember continuous learning
keeps you at the Forefront of cyber
security and ensures you will well
prepared to protect digital assets and
now we'll move to the step six that is
gain practical experience gaining
practical experience in ethical hacking
is crucial for horning your skills
participate in Capture the Flag
competitions CDF where you can solve
real world challenges and learn to think
like a hacker explore Hands-On labs and
exercises that allow you to practice
various hacking techniques in a
controlled environment engage with
ethical hacking communities share
knowledge and collaborate on projects to
build a strong practical foundation in
cyber security and then comes the step
seven seek employment to seek employment
as an ethical hacker craft a resume
highlighting your skills certifications
and experience look for opportunities in
Industries such as Finance Healthcare
and tech companies with cyber security
is Paramount network with Professionals
in the field explore job boards and
leverage online platforms ethical
hackers are in high demand so be
proactive in your job search and
showcase your commitment to safeguarding
digital assets and then comes the step
eight keep evolving keep evolving the
world of ethical hacking is constantly
changing to stay at the Forefront or be
curious Embrace new technologies and
adapt to emerging threats regularly
update your skills earn Advanced
certifications and network with fellow
heckers remember the cyber security
landscape evolves and so should you stay
ethical committed and dedicated to
safeguarding the digital realm and now
move to the job roles and average salary
so the first job role for an ethical eer
is security analyst and the average
salary in United States is
$150,000 perom and in India it's 11
lakhs perom and then becomes the
penetration tester and its average
salary in United States is
$145,000 perom and in India it's 13 laks
perom and then comes security consultant
its average salary in United States is
$120,000 perom and in India it's 10
lakhs perom and then comes security
engineer its average salary in United
States is
$156,000 perom and in India it's 8 lakhs
perom and then comes the incident
respondo its average salary in United
States is $115,000 perom and in India
it's 7 lakhs perom and now moving to the
companies hiring cyber Security
Professionals or ethical hackers so the
companies are Amazon aseno Google Apple
and Intel so these are the top most
companies and there are tons of
companies that hire ethical hackers so
in conclusion the ethical hacker road
map for 2024 is your key to a promising
and rewarding career in cyber security
as the digital realm expands so do the
threats and ethical hackers are the
Frontline Defenders Embrace this journey
and you will not only have a secure
future but also the opportunity to be
part of something bigger protecting the
digital world from malicious intent and
this was all for this tutorial hope you
guys found it informative and helpful
exciting topic to discuss and that show
to pick the interest of all the aspiring
ethical hackers out there we will be
diving deep into the top skills required
for ethical hacking whether you are a
beginner looking to get started or a
seasoned Pro looking to refine your
skills this video has something for
everyone and before starting if you are
an aspiring cyber security professional
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice this course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and this course requires
just a bachelor's degree with a 50%
average and no prior programming
experience and one plus year of work
experience is preferred for more details
you can use the tap link mentioned in
the description box below and pin
comment so let's get started so first
we'll have an introduction to ethical
hacking that is before we delve into the
skills let's first understand what
ethical hacking is ethical hackers also
known as Whitehead hackers are cyber
Security Experts who legally breach
systems to identify vulnerabilities and
weaknesses their mission is to protect
organizations and individuals from cyber
threats and to become a successful
ethical hacker you need to master
several key skills so let's get started
with the key skills so the first skill
is excellent computer skills to become
an effective ethical hacker you first
need excellent computer skills this
involves quickly grasping and utilizing
new technologies thinking creatively to
identify potential vulnerabilities
exploiting those vulnerabilities and
documenting your work for application
without these core skills it's
challenging to perform ethical hacking
effectively moving to the next skill
that is strong foundation in networking
so the skill you need is a strong
foundation in networking you must
understand how Network operate including
protocols IP addressing subnets and
routers without this knowledge you won't
be able to effectively anal analyze and
secure network systems and then comes
the third skill that is Proficiency in
operating systems so skill number three
is Proficiency in operating systems an
ethical hacker should be comfortable
with a variety of os platforms such as
Windows Linux and Mac OS this knowledge
is essential for understanding
vulnerabilities and exploiting them
Linux is an invaluable operating system
for ethical hackers it provides access
to system internals and potential
vulnerabilities Linux skills empowers
acers to create custom scripts and
programs for task automation hands-on
experience with various Linux
distributions is the most effective way
to learn and customize tools and
techniques and then comes the next skill
that is programming and scripting so
programming skills are fundamental to
ethical hacking ethical hackers use
their coding knowledge to discover
vulnerabilities and propos Solutions
Common programming languages used in
ethical hacking include python Java or
PHP a strong understanding of coding is
necessary to comprehend how systems
operate and where weaknesses might hide
so this was the fourth skill now moving
to the next skill that is database
skills so ethical hackers must Master
database skills understanding how
databases are structured and function is
crucial for identifying security
vulnerabilities Proficiency in database
management tools enables hackers to
manipulate data and access restricted
information that is a vital skill for
the job crafting SQL queries to extract
information from database is essential
to find vulnerabilities an ethical
hackers deep knowledge of how database
work and how to use SQL for manipulation
is a critical skill now mov to the next
skill that is the sixth skill and that
is understanding of cyber security
Concepts an in-depth understanding of
cyber security Concepts is a must you
should be well versed in cyber security
models encryption access control and
risk management knowing how malicious
hackers operate will help you defend
against them now moving to the next
skill that is web application security
web application security is crucial in
today's digital landscape you need to be
skilled in identifying and fixing
vulnerabilities like SQL injection crite
scripting and cross site request forgery
to protect web applications from attacks
now moving to the next skill that is
familiarity with security tools
familiarity with security tools is skill
number tools like wi shock metas sploit
and map and BB suit are essential for
scanning analyzing and exploiting
vulnerabilities mastering these tools
will give you a significant advantage
and then comes the next skill that is
cryptography cryptography plays a
crucial role in ethical hacking it
involves encrypting and decrypting
information to protect data from
unauthorized access ethical hackers use
cryptography to safeguard information
and create back doors into systems
allowing access to sensitive data
without raising alarms and then comes
the next skill that is problem solving
and critical thinking ethical hackers
should have strong problem solving and
critical thinking skills you will often
encounter complex security challenges
that require Creative Solutions being
able to think outside the box is a
valuable skill and then comes the next
skill that is continuous learning our
final skill is a commitment to
continuous learning the world of cyber
security evolves rapidly and new threats
and techniques emerge all the time
staying up to date with the latest
trends and Technologies is vital to
maintaining your Effectiveness as an
ethical hacker and now moving to job
roles and average salary for various
cyber security roles starting with
security analyst so the average salary
in us for security analyst is
$150,000 and in India it's 11 lakhs
perom and if we talk about the
penetration tester and now moving to the
next tole that is penetration tester and
the average salary for penetration
tester in US is
$145,000 perom and in India it's 13
lakhs perom and the the next role is
security consultant and the average
salary in us for this role is
$120,000 perom and in India it's 10
lakhs perom and moving to the next role
that is security engineer and the
average salary for this role in US is
$156,000 perom and in India it is 8
lakhs perom moving to the next role that
is incident responder and the average
salary for this role in US is
$15,000 perom and in India it's 7 lakhs
perom and now moving to the companies
hiring cyber Security Professionals and
the top most companies are Amazon asenta
Google Apple and Intel and in conclusion
ethical hacking is a challenging but
immensely rewarding field that Demands a
diverse set of core Tech skills these
skills from computer proficiency to
critical thinking enable ethical hackers
to safeguard computer systems and
networks from potential threats if
you're looking to enter this exciting
domain make sure to develop and refine
these skills if you want to become a
cyber security expert and gain handsome
salary packages look at a wide range of
cyber security courses offered by simply
learn and that is in collaboration with
top universities across the globe and a
year of experience is preferred to
enroll in these courses you can find the
course link mentioned in the description
box below and pin comment and make sure
to subscribe to our Channel now there
are several reasons as to why you should
learn cyber security here we have the
top 10 reasons for the same at number 10
the reason we have is basic requirements
there is a wrong notion that building a
career in cyber security is daunting
well it is not a fancy college degree is
not at all that it takes to become a
successful cyber security professional
you can Venture into the domain of cyber
security with some basic knowledge of it
and with an authorized cyber security
certification the overall elig ility
Criterion for the cyber security domain
is relaxing across the world it
professionals with cyber security
certifications are known to receive
higher salary packages certifications
are always given extra weightage in the
infosec field and it opens doors to
bigger
opportunities these cyber security
certifications can be opted by anyone as
the eligibility for these are very basic
cyber security certifications train
professionals and thus helps in Bridging
the Gap between the supply and demand of
skilled cyber security
professionals so don't take a step back
from learning cyber security thinking it
is a tedious process if you are a
fresher or a professional you can go
ahead with just these basic
requirements before moving on to our
next reason here is a question for you
all how many of you like mathematics
please let us know in the comment
section below I'm sure not everyone
loves mathematics and that is completely
okay when it comes to learning cyber
security
and our ninth reason is mathematics is
not a concern for learning cyber
security many of us find mathematics
challenging some have the aptitude for
dealing with numbers and some don't and
for those who don't they find it
difficult to proceed with a career that
has maths
involved however you can take your
decision without any worries when it
comes to Cy security as the domain of
cyber security does not involve
mathematics so if maths is is not your
strong point then choosing to learn
cyber security is a great choice this
can definitely be a relief to many
instead you can get acquainted with
networking network security control and
coding to build a career in cyber
security our eighth reason is that cyber
security is a profession that helps
achieve the greater good cyber security
consists of a set of measures and
approaches that help companies and
individuals data from being compromised
and
stolen cyber security professionals have
defended organizations from several
deadly cyber attacks that aimed at
jeopardizing an organization's
confidentiality integrity and
availability cyber crimes are currently
on the rise with different types of
cyber attacks the threat to
organizations and individuals alike is
only growing by the day government
agencies police forces and cyber crime
cells are tackling this threat however
there is more requirement for skilled
cyber security profession professionals
who can protect data and work for the
greater good therefore if you want to
bring about a positive impact and a
meaningful difference to the society we
live in then learning cyber security is
a great choice our seventh reason is
that you get to travel the
world who doesn't love to travel the
globe learning cyber security is a great
reason especially for those of you who
aspire to travel the world with the lack
of cyber Security Professionals in the
world there are plenty of opportunities
for skilled experts to travel overseas
to Showcase their cyber security skills
which are in high demand The increased
demand for cyber Security Professionals
is not just restricted to one area but
to the entire world there are several
employment opportunities for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
so learning cyber security can open new
doors for you overseas as well our sixth
reason is very interesting and that is
the fact that you get to work with
secret agencies and high-profile work
ones like other
professionals cyber Security
Professionals also have the opportunity
to work with several prestigious
multinational companies and big giants
like Google Dell Accenture and others
however a cyber Security Professionals
career opportunities can go beyond mnc's
and they might get the opportunity to
work with top government secret agencies
like mosad NSA ni FBI and so on so what
are you waiting for become a cyber
security expert and showcase your skills
to grab the chance to work with these
top agencies our fifth reason is it is
never too late to begin with there are
very few professions that give you the
Liberty to begin late and one such
profession is cyber security it is never
too late to realize that you want to
become a cyber security expert many
people work as cyber Security
Professionals even after the retirement
if they have a good knowledge about
it you could could also join cyber
security courses that train you
irrespective of your
age as long as you have good cyber
security skills there is no need to
worry about job security however late it
is our fourth reason is cyber security
is an evergreen industry cyber security
has gradually become an evergreen
industry in the current times with the
onset of the coid 19 pandemic businesses
are moving online and shifting to cloud
storage the demand for cyber security is
at its peak
there is a high demand for cyber
Security Experts who can Safeguard
Digital Data hence we can be rest
assured that cyber security is here to
stay and this domain is only going to
grow in the coming
years according to cyber security
Ventures the number of Internet users
will hit a whooping 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this reveals the growing demand for
cyber Security Professionals across the
globe dig digitalization is taking place
across several
Industries a cyber security expert finds
opportunities in every field as every
organization wants to be secure on the
digital front so now is the right time
if you are looking to learn and start a
career in cyber security before moving
to our top three reasons to learn cyber
security here's some crucial information
for you
all as you know with relevant
certifications you can grow your cyber
security career and here we are to help
you with
that you can check out Simply learns
cyber security expert Masters program to
equip you with the necessary skills to
become an expert in this rapidly growing
domain training for highly short after
certifications like CompTIA Security
Plus CH cism and cissp is at the
Forefront of this course preparing you
for the industry's best jobs so what are
you waiting for get certified with
simply loan and grow your career in in
cyber security
today so our third reason to learn cyber
security is because of the plenty of job
opportunities it offers according to the
US Bureau of Labor Statistics the
employment of information security
analysts is projected to grow 33% from
2020 to 2030 much faster than the
average for all
occupations with the world turning
digital there is a dire need for
companies to hire cyber Security Experts
who can protect and Safeguard sensitive
data as firms work to improve their
cyber security structure they are also
hiring several cyber Security Experts to
design Implement and maintain the Cyber
Security
Solutions cyber security jobs are not
limited to the it domain many security
positions are found at companies outside
of it including Industries like Media
Sports or Finance to name a few this
emphasizes on the fact that a cyber
secur export is exposed to several job
opportunities from different types of
companies across the
globe our second reason for you to learn
cyber security is the good salary
package it
offers salaries play a crucial part in
any job that you undertake isn't it
every individual likes to get duly
rewarded for their work and cyber
security is one such domain that
provides fat
paychecks cyber Security Experts are the
individuals who have come to the rescue
with the unprecedented rise in cyber
crimes across the world organizations
are willing to pay Skyhigh salaries for
these cyber security exports there is a
lack of skilled cyber Security
Professionals and this is another reason
cyber Security Experts are paid
well the salaries of cyber Security
Professionals are still expected to grow
in the coming times owing to the high
demand salaries and cyber security have
a high growth potential and if you are a
skilled cyber security professional you
can always NE negotiate your
salary finally a top reason to learn
cyber security is that you will have a
job that never gets boring and a domain
that offers unlimited potential for
personal
growth several times individuals find
themselves lost in their career due to
lack of challenges due to their mundane
work and also due to stagnation at work
these reion play a major role when it
comes to a professional quitting their
job however a job role in cyber security
tackles these reasons to an extent and
that is why we have this reason at
number one cyber security is a domain
that is constantly evolving and so are
the nature of cyber attacks hackers are
always trying to develop new methods to
get to your data they develop new
exploits regularly and hence as a cyber
security professional you will face
interesting challenges to find Optimal
Solutions for new exploits you will have
new puzzles to solve a cyber security
career is not going to be
stale along with failures you will also
be exposed to new and interesting
discoveries to keep yourself updated in
this field and to tackle cyber attacks
you should be in a position to outsmart
the hackers being in the field of cyber
security allows you to constantly
upskill and enhance your knowledge and
experience it also ensures that your
Learning Journey will never stop with
the world turning virtual cyber attacks
are constantly flooding new headlines Co
19 accelerated the current digital
transformation and the year 2020
witnessed several data breaches since
technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives it is no surprise
that the need for skilled cyber Security
Professionals is increasing on that note
hey everyone welcome yet to another
exciting video by simply learn which
will take you through the top cyber
security career options available today
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and that
Bell icon for interesting Tech videos
every day there is a significant lack of
skilled cyber security professionals who
can tackle the cyber security challenges
faced daily hence a career in cyber
security is demanding and equally
rewarding finding the right career path
in the cyber security industry isn't
always easy here we are here to help you
with that there are a few prerequisites
for a career in cyber security the basic
one being a bachelor's degree in a
subject relating to cyber security
however if you don't have a relevant
degree you can always take up relevant
cyber security certifications and
Kickstart your cyber security Journey a
few other skills like networking
knowledge of operating systems and Cloud
security are required to start and grow
your cyber security career you can check
out our video on the top five cyber
security skills to no more cyber
security jobs vary from entry level to
Executive management and everything in
between there are several cyber security
pads available today it is best if you
start with entry level and then move on
to the next level with the help of
certifications and relevant experience
here let us have a look at the top five
cyber security job roles today the first
job roll is that of a network engineer
Network Engineers construct and
administer a company's computer networks
they are responsible for installing
configuring and supporting Network
equipment they also configure and
maintain firewalls switch and routers
this entry-level cyber security job can
help you start your journey to become an
ethical hacker the annual average salary
of a network engineer in the US is
$85,900 and in India it is around
$510,000 rupees second on our list is
information security analyst as an
information security analyst your
primary duty is to protect sensitive
information information security
analysts create and Implement plans for
preventing cyber attacks they monitor
data access and ensure compliance with
policies depending on the Cyber threat
they decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the US an
information security analyst earns $
89,1 140 annually and in India they earn
64275 rupees third on our list is
ethical hacker they're also known as
penetration testers they are Network
Security Consultants who ident ify and
exploit system vulnerabilities just like
how a hacker would do they probe and
test the network using various
penetration tools and software they also
design new penetration tools and
document the test results in the US a
certified ethical hacker earns around
$93,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 5 lakh rupees
the fourth job roll that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security Architects research and plan
the security elements for for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks a security
architect approves the installation of
routers VPN and firewalls their duties
go beyond just architecture building and
including formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides security
architects in the US make a handsome sum
of
$124,000 a year on an average and in
India they make nearly
218,000 r piece and finally fifth on our
list is Chief Information Security
Officer ciso they are senior level
officers in an organization they ensure
the safety of the information they
develop Implement and maintain
information security and risk management
programs they also interact with
stakeholders and regularly brief them
with information security concerns the
average annual salary of a chief
information security officer in the
states is a whopping 165,000
annually and in India it is 22 lak
22845 rupees several companies are
looking for skilled cyber Security
Professionals Phillips Seamans Google
Microsoft and GE to name a few with
passion the right amount of experience
and relevant certifications you can grow
your cyber security career you can check
out Simply learn cyber security expert
Masters program to equip you with the
necessary skills needed to become an
expert in this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more according to cyber crime magazine
by cyber security Ventures globally
there would be nearly 3.5 million
unfilled cyber security jobs by 2021 and
the number of Internet users will hit a
Waring 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this shows the growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber Security Professionals let us help
you start your cyber security career by
bagging the right skill
set many of you out there might be
waiting to become a cyber security
professional but are unsure of how to go
about it and what skills you would need
to get a cyber security job not to worry
we are here to help you with that after
extensive research we have come up with
the top five skills that will help you
get into the field of cyber security
let's have a look at these skills
individually first we have networking
and system administration the number one
skill you need to have to enter the
field of cyber security is computer
networking networking is the backbone of
the internet it is imperative that you
have an in-depth understanding of
networking to start a career in cyber
security a network is a group of
interconnected devices and networking is
the art of understanding how data is
sent transmitted and received amongst
these
devices you need to know various routing
protocols the tcpip and OSI models
govern networking The OSI model is
comparatively newer basically in these
models all the protocols are grouped
into layers and work together to help
you receive data on your device sent
from a server learning networking will
help you understand the technical
aspects of data transmission which will
help you secure your data you can take
up networking certifications like
Security Plus and Cisco CCNA to gain a
strong networking
Foundation another skill that will be
beneficial for you is to Master System
Administration if you think about it all
of us are CIS admins at some
level system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit carry out a trial
and error method and give yourself small
tasks like recovering deleted files or
monitoring old viruses on a VM explore
new techniques put them into use and
expand your
knowledge let us now move on to our
second skill knowledge of operating
systems and virtual
machines to become a cyber security
professional you need to have a strong
knowledge of operating environments such
as Windows Linux and Mac OS cyber
Security Professionals largely use Linux
and it comes with several tools to learn
operating systems go ahead and set up
and use Virtual machines that is VMS and
play around with them this will help you
gain hands-on experience as a cyber
security expert you should be
comfortable working on any OS WMS allow
you to train and research in an isolated
environment and help you maximize your
skills the next point to remember is to
know Ki Linux it is the most widely
known Linux distribution for ethical
hacking and penetration testing it comes
with several hundred tools related to
penetration testing malware analysis
security research computer forensics and
so on Kali contains several projects and
you can learn a lot another good thing
about Kali is that it is free to use so
what are you waiting for download and
start right away remember that Linux is
the backbone of cyber security and a
commonly asked topic for cyber security
interviews especially for pent testing
roles moving on to our third skill our
third skill is network security control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network it is
simple you can only Safeguard your
network if you know how it works how
routers firewalls and other devices work
a firewall is a hardware or software
that blocks incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer
firewalls are required to secure a
network as a cyber security expert you
must be able to leverage a firewall to
filter and prevent unauthorized traffic
onto the network in addition to that as
a cyber security expert you must know
about intrusion detection systems
intrusion prevention systems virtual
private networks and remote
access an intrusion detection system IDs
is designed to detect unauthorized
access to a system it is used together
with a firewall and a router you should
be able to operate the IDS and recognize
any security policy violations and
malicious traffic on the
network as many of you may have used a
VPN is a connection between a VPN server
and a VPN client it is a secure tunnel
across the
internet moving on next up we have an
interesting skill any idea what that is
if yes pause and leave a comment as to
what you think the next skill will be if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more and before we jump into this skill
if you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up fourth skill
on our list is coding so you might be
wondering if coding is really required
to become a cyber security professional
well it is true that not all cyber
Security Professionals have or need
coding skills
however having zero coding knowledge May
limit your opportunities in the future
knowing a couple of programming
languages will help you identify the
plan behind an attack and defend against
deadly hacking
techniques so as seen on your screens
these are the best programming languages
to learn to make your cyber security
career
worthwhile we have C and C++ the C
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems C and C++ are
low-level programming language anges
that you need to know as a cyber
security professional on the other hand
python is a highlevel programming
language that is becoming popular among
cyber Security Experts today knowing
python will give you an upper hand in
your career it will help you identify
and fix
vulnerabilities JavaScript is another
highlevel programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages a good
advantage of knowing JavaScript is that
you can prevent cross-side scripting
attacks from occurring as in these
attacks the attacker implants malicious
code in a web application speaking of
PHP because most of the websites are
created using PHP learning it will help
you defend against
Intruders similarly HTML is another
language cyber Security Professionals
should understand as most websites use
it and it is one of the easiest
languages to learn another programming
language that you can use is goang it is
great for cryptography you can solve
various cyber security problems with it
then we have SQL that is structured
query language attackers use this
language to damage the stored data one
such example is the SQL injection attack
hence having a good understanding of SQL
will be highly beneficial another Point
we'd like to highlight is to have
knowledge of Assembly Language this will
help you become a cyber security
engineer assembly will help you
understand how malware functions and
thereby help you defend against it in
the cyber security domain you can't just
lock into a single language and hence it
is advised that you're acquainted with a
couple of them you can also do a crash
course for these languages and learn
them hence determine the best
programming language for your cyber
security role and get familiar with the
basics moving on our fifth skill on the
list is cloud security there is a
growing demand for cyber Security
Professionals with Cloud security skills
in the coming
years companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid Cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
and aure more organizations look to
Cloud infrastructure to store data and
run
applications this includes
implementation of policies and
technologies that protect cloud-based
systems and
devices just like application
development security Cloud security also
involves building secure systems from
the start companies want professionals
who can manage the cloud security tools
to identify and prevent any Cloud
breaches people with experience and
knowledge in managing big plat platforms
such as Microsoft Azure AWS and the gcp
are in high demand now that we have seen
the top five cyber security skills let
us go through a set of additional skills
that can help you get into the cyber
security field remember that to become a
successful cyber security expert you
must possess a rich and diverse skill
set so in a list of additional skills
first we have risk
analysis identifying risks even before
their arrival is a great skill cyber
Security Professionals are required to
identify manage and mitigate risks risk
management and mitigation is a skill set
that is going to be highly in demand in
the coming
years next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized taxes here in demand
skills are authentication authorization
malware analysis and data
recovery next on our list is security
incident handling and
response as a cyber security expert you
must be prepared to handle any
forthcoming threat of violating an
organization security policy by
following an updated incident response
plan your team can proactively protect
your data and minimize the
damages in security Incident Management
you required to identify manage record
and analyze security threats in real
time a security incident can be an
active threat or a successful compromise
of data or an attempted intrusion it can
also be incidents like dos attacks
fishing AP is ransomware rent many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and event management S tools
and
services moving on we have security
audit security auditing is an internal
check that is carried out to find flaws
in the organization's information system
you must be able to conduct a review of
the organization's adherance to
regulatory guidelines security audit and
compliance knowledge are very crucial as
any mystery of Regulatory Compliance
could lead to Hefty penalties soon
organizations will need people who are
more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the
regulations finally we have loss and
regulations and often overlooked cyber
security aspect there are several cyber
security laws and regulations ation s
and if you break these laws
intentionally or not it doesn't matter
as you will still be charged these laws
Define how you can use the internet and
it also defines how people can be
protected from becoming the victims of
cyber crimes knowing these laws and
regulations and following the best
practice will make you ethical at your
job and this will in turn be good for
your organization so those were our list
of additional skills apart from these
make sure you stay updated with new
hacks and learn new tools as cyber
security is ever
evolving another important skill apart
from these technical skills is your soft
skills having a set of good soft skills
will help you bag your dream job we have
a video on the top five soft skills that
will help you grow in your career do
watch that and incorporate those skills
as well we humans are highly techsavvy
in today's times with the extensive use
of the internet and modern Technologies
there is a massive challenge in
protecting all our Digital Data such as
net banking information account
credentials and medical reports to name
a few have you heard about the deadly
one to cry ransomware attack the attack
happened in May 2017 in Asia and then it
spread across the world within a day
more than 23,000 computers were infected
across 150 countries the oneac cry
crypto worm encrypted the data and
locked the users out of their systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to $600
in Bitcoin the users who used the
unsupported version of Microsoft Windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of April 2017 were
targeted in this attack the one a cry
attack took a toll on every sector top
tier organizations like Itachi Nissan
and FedEx had to put their businesses on
hold as their systems were affected too
now this is what you call a Cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented
we can Define cyber security as the
practice of protecting networks programs
computer systems and their components
from unauthorized digital attacks these
illegal attacks are often referred to as
hacking hacking refers to exploiting
weaknesses in a computer network to
obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems this
is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong there are hackers who work
with different motives let's have a look
at three different types of hackers
black hat hackers are individuals who
illegally hack into a system for a
monetary gain on the contrary we have
white hat hackers who exploit the
vulnerabilities in a system by hacking
into it with permission in order to
defend the organization this form of
hacking is absolutely legal and ethical
hence they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers in addition to these
hackers we also have the greyh Hat
hackers as the name suggests the the
color gray is a blend of both white and
black these hackers discover
vulnerabilities in a system and report
it to the system's owner which is a good
act but they do this without seeking the
owner's approval sometimes gry hat
hackers also ask for money in return for
the spotted
vulnerabilities now that you have seen
the different types of hackers let's
understand more about the hacking that
is legal and valid ethical hacking
through an interesting story Dan runs a
Trading Company he does online training
with the money his customers invest
everything was going well and Dan's
business was booming until a hacker
decided to hack the company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts he asked for a
lumpsum ransome in exchange for the
stolen credentials Dan took the Hacker's
words lightly and didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and Dan
was liable to pay back the customers Dan
lost a lot of money and also the trust
of his customers after this incident Dan
gave a lot of thought as to what could
have gone wrong with the security
infrastructure in his company he wished
there was someone from his company who
could have run a test attack to see how
vulnerable systems were before the
hacker penetrated into the network this
was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
Network before an outsider does to do
this job he hired an ethical hacker John
JN was a skilled professional who worked
precisely like a hacker in no time he
spotted several vulnerabilities in Dan's
organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation so now you know hacking is
not always bad JN in this scenario
expose the vulnerabilities in the
existing Network and such hacking is
known as ethical hacking ethical hacking
is distributed into six different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how JN our ethical
hacker will act before launching an
attack the first step Jon takes is to
gather all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like inmap
and hping for this purpose John then
tries to spot the vulnerabilities if any
in the Target system using tools like
inmap and NEX poose this is the scanning
phase now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access after Jon makes his way through
the organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the Target
system the metas sploit tool helps him
with this this phase is called
maintaining access Jon is a brilliant
hacker hence he tries his best not to
leave any evidence of his attack this is
the fifth phase clearing tracks we now
have the last phase that is reported in
this phase Jon documents a summary of
his entire attack the vulnerabilities he
spotted the tools he used and the
success rate of the attack looking into
the report Dan is now able to take a
call and see how to protect his
organization from any external cyber
attacks don't you all think JN is an
asset to any organization if you want to
become an ethical hacker like John then
there are a few skills that you need to
acquire first and foremost you need to
have a good knowledge of operating
environments such as Windows Linux Unix
and Macintosh you must have reasonably
good knowledge of programming languages
such as HTML PHP python SQL and
JavaScript networking is the base of
ethical hacking hence you should be good
at it ethical hackers should be well
aware of security laws so that they
don't misuse their skills finally you
must have a global certification on
ethical hacking to successfully bag a
position of an ethical hacker like John
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification C CompTIA pentest
plus and licensed penetration test
certification to name a few simply learn
provides a cyber security expert
master's program that will equip you
with all the skills required by a cyber
security expert you could have a look at
it by clicking the link in the
description so let's start it with what
is ethical hacking now plainly defined
ethical hacking is locating weaknesses
or vulnerabilities of computers and
information systems using the intent and
actions of a malicious hacker the major
difference is here that we are hired to
discover those weak weaknesses in a
legal and ethical manner that means
first and foremost our intent should not
be malicious we do not wish any harm to
the organization and whatever we
discover is reported back and not
misused once we report back we would
also be trying to help them out to
mitigate or remove those weaknesses or
vulnerabilities to enhance the company
security posture so essentially we would
have the same training or the same
knowledge as that of a malicious hacker
except that the intent is going to be
different the intent is going to help
the organization achieve security to
protect themselves against malicious
hackers and the second most important
thing about ethical hacking is that we
are authorized to do that activity I
cannot in good faith hack somebody and
then tell them you know what I just I
just wanted to help you out and uh here
are your vulnerabilities and uh this is
the way you can prevent them I first
need the authorization from the other
party and only then can I perform an
ethical hack so in this example hacker
attacks an individual with malicious
intent and makes misuse of whatever
information they have gotten they steal
the data they maybe fry the operating
system Hardware destroy it and thus uh
they leave the victim without uh a
device with authorization an ethical
hacker can also attack the same
individual minus the destruction of
course and the intent is good so they're
willingly finding out the
vulnerabilities and helping the victim
plug them out so that they wouldn't be a
victim of a malicious attack now here
the first thing is authorization from
the victim and the second thing is the
good intent where we do not misuse those
vulnerabilities and we report them back
to the victim or to the client and help
them uh patch those vulnerabilities
that's the main difference between a
white hat and a black hat so Security
Experts are normally termed as white hat
hackers malicious hackers are termed as
black hats now the responsibilities of
ethical hacker are multifold first and
foremost you have to create scripts test
for vulnerabilities first have to
identify those in the first place so
there's a vulnerability assessment
identifying those vulnerabilities and
then you going to test them to see the
validity and the complexity of those
vulnerabilities so your one of your
responsibilities would be to develop
tools to increase security as well or to
configure Security in such a way that it
would be difficult to breach performing
risk assessment now what is a risk risk
is a threat that is posed to an
organization by a possibility of getting
hacked so let's say I as a ethical
hacker run a vulnerability scanner on a
particular client I identify 10
different vulnerabilities within those
10 vulnerabilities I do a risk
assessment to identify which
vulnerability is critical would have the
most impact on the client and what would
be the
could not only be loss of data it could
be Financial losses it could be loss of
reputation penalties they have to pay to
the client for breaches or penalties
that they may have to pay for pay the
governments in case of breaches that
happened that uh couldn't be controlled
another responsibility of the ethical
hacker is to set up policies in such a
way that it becomes difficult for
hackers to get access to devices or to
protected data and finally train the
staff for network security so uh we've
got a lot of employees in an
organization we need to train the staff
of what is allowed and what is not
allowed how to keep themselves secure so
that they don't get compromised thus
becoming a vulnerability themselves to
the organization the policies that we
have talked about are administrative
policies to govern the employees of the
organization for example password
policies most of the organizations will
have a tough password policy where they
say you have to create a password that
meets a certain level of complexity
before that can be accepted and till you
create that password password you're not
allowed to log in or you're not allowed
to register so let's move on to
understand what is penetration testing
now for penetration testing there is a
phase called vulnerability assessment
that happens before this vulnerability
assessment is nothing but running a
scanning tool to identify a list of
potential flaws or vulnerabilities
within the organization once you have
identified the list of those
vulnerabilities you would then move on
to penetration test this is the part of
ethical hacking where it specifically
focuses on penetration only of the
information system systems so you have
identified that flaw maybe it could be a
database with a SQL injection or it
could be uh a buffer over overrun flaw
or it could be a simple password
cracking attempt your idea is to create
those tools create those attacks and try
to penetrate into those areas where
security is weak uh the essense of
penetration testing is to penetrate
Information Systems using various
attacks the attacks could be anything
like a fishing attack a password
cracking attack a denial of service
attack or any other world of that you
have identified during the volum scan so
what is Ki Linux and why is it used Ki
Linux is an operating system oftenly
used by hackers and ethical hackers both
because of the tool sets that the
operating system contains it is a
Operating System created by
professionals with a lot of embedded
tools it is a dbn based operating system
with Advanced penetration testing and
security auditing features there are
more than 600 plus odd tools on that
operating system that can help you
leverage any of the attacks man in the
midle attacks sniffing password cracking
any of these attacks would be possible
with all the tools available you just
need to know how to utilize the
operating system and its tools contains
like I said hund of hundreds of tools
that are used for various information
security tasks like uh computer
forensics rever reverse engineering
information finding even uh getting
access to different machines and then uh
creating viruses worms Trojans anything
that you will will 600 plus tools in the
K Linux operating system there are
periodic updates that are given out to
the operating system as well it is open
source that means it is free to utilize
you can even have the source code you
can modify it if you want to there's
customizations available for all the
tools you can download third party tools
and install them if you want there's a
white support for wireless uh network
cards multiple languages are being
supported at the time at the same time
as well and you can create a lot of
attach in uh scripts you can create
attacking tools and you can write your
own exploits as well on K Linux so this
all all in all helps you create a very
robust system where you can create your
own attacks and then launch them against
unsuspecting victims now that is illegal
so as far ethical hacking is concerned
once you have authorization you're going
to identify which tools should be
utilized you're going to get the
appropriate permissions and only then
are you going to attempt those attacks
let's talk about the phases of
penetration testing now there are five
different phases the first one is the
recognizance phase also known as the
information gathering phase this is the
most important phase for any hacker this
is where the hacker or the ethical
hacker if you will will gather as much
information about the targets victim or
V vers the V the victim right so once
you have that information you would then
be able to identify what tool sets to
include and how to attack the victim for
example you want to find out the IP
addresses the do domains subdomains the
network architecture that is being
utilized you want to identify operating
systems that are being utilized the
network IP ranges that are being
utilized and so on so forth you might
want to identify employees within an
organization for social engineering
attacks in the future email addresses
telephone numbers anything and
everything that will help you validate
and give you information about the
target is something that you want to do
in the recognizance phase at this point
in time we are not going to question
whether whatever information we are
getting is useful or not only time will
tell depending on the various attacks
that we will be building up later on
this becomes your Bas line this becomes
your database with all the information
about the victim so that you can come
back from later stages back to the
recognizance phase to look at the
information that you have gathered and
then you can f tune your attacks once
you have done that you're going to uh
then start the scanning phase based on
the information that you have gathered
you're going to identify live machines
within the network once you've
identified the live machines you'll scan
SC them for open ports protocols and
procedures any processes that are
running and then we going to identify
vulnerabilities Within These processes
and Within These open ports so in the
scanning phase uh why do we need to find
live machines because we want to find
out the machines that have booted up
have an operating system and are running
on the network if an machine is not
available on the network or is in a
shutdown mode that machine cannot be
hacked through a technical attack then
it will be a physical attack where you
physically go to the machine and then do
whatever you want to do with it for a
technical attack you will have to
identify the machines that have booted
up then you're going to scan the open
ports because that's going to be our
entry point and on the port would be a
service that is running so you scan the
service as well identify the version of
the service and then do a vulnerability
scan to identify if there are any
vulnerabilities on those services that
are running and then based on all of
this information we are going to develop
our attacks as we go on so once we have
this we go on to the gaining access
phace where we are going to attack and
try to get access to our victims
machines could be a social engineering
attack based on the information
gathering we have done in the technical
assessment in scanning phase if you have
identified a vulnerability you're going
to identify a relevant exploit and then
use that exploit to try to gain access
or we might just craft a Trojan and try
to uh execute that trojen on the
victim's machine to uh check if we can
get access through that particular
manner once we have the access could be
even a simple password password cracking
attack which we have been able to
accomplish and we have cracked the
password of the person and now we have
gained access to that person's computer
right but these attacks would be
temporary for example we have cracked a
password somebody changes the password
every 30 days after that period our
attack would be useless if a Trojan is
executed we get a connection to that
machine for once but then how do we get
get a repeated connection over and over
again if you want to reconnect to that
machine so that's where we come into the
maintaining access phase where we
install uh root kits key loggers
sniffers and things like that where we
could get a back door entry to the
victim's machine if we have already been
successfully installed a Trojan we would
want to add the trojen to the startup
menu so that every time the operating
system starts the Trojan gets
automatically executed and thus we
maintain the back door entry to that
victim's machine once we have done all
of this all these activities are going
to leave a trace in the victim's machine
so if you install a Trojan a being an
application would create directories and
files a virus would be destructive in
nature if you're executing a script it
will leave some logs behind if we even
log in through the cracked password that
we have it will create a login entry at
for that particular time stamp along
with the IP address that we utilized in
the covering tracks we are essentially
trying to avoid detection by deleting
traces of our activity that means that
we need to identify where logs have been
stored we need to address those logs and
we need to delete them or modify them in
such a way that our activity is not
traceable so these are the five main
phases of a penetration test gather as
much information as you can scan for
machines ports protocols and services
running on the victim's device try to
gain access by password cracking cions
exploits for the vulnerabilities if any
maintain that access by installing
further software which will allow you to
get back door access to that particular
system and then try to cover your tracks
by deleting all traces of your activity
once successful the victim will have no
idea and you have a backd door entry and
you can monitor the victim to the extent
that you want now in an ethical Hacker's
perspective this penetration test can be
done in multiple aspects so again
understand the fact that we are doing an
authorized activity we have identified
the tools that we have to use identified
the attacks we have got the appropriate
authorization and based on that
authorization we are conducting a
penetration test the penetration test
may be asked to be done in one of these
manners first is the blackb test the
blackbox test is where no information is
given to the ethical hacker about the it
infrastructure so they have no idea what
it is they start right from the first
phase of the information gathering
gather as much information they can and
based on the gathered information they
try to create and launch attacks to see
if they are going to be successful now
not only does it test the knowledge of
the penetration tester it would also
test the security implementations that
the organization has done to see whether
they can identify the attack and prevent
it in the first place so this is the
simulation of a malicious hacker
scenario where a malicious hacker having
no idea about the organization first
tries to gather information and then
tries to attack that organization so no
source code knowledge no technological
knowledge nothing they're just going to
try to gather information scan those
devices and then try to gain access the
second test is a gray box test where
some information is given or some
knowledge of the it infrastructure is
given think of it from a employees
perspective a regular employee in an
organization who doesn't have extra
privileges like an administrator but
it's just a a regular employee does that
means that they got limited access
within the organization based on which
they get some knowledge of the it
infrastructure so this is an attempt of
an Insider uh simulation attack where a
regular user may want to try to misuse
the access that they've been given and
then try to gather information or try to
gain access to other devices which they
are not authorized to the third test is
white box where there's full knowledge
of the it infrastructure that has been
given so this is again a simulation of
an Insider attack a malicious Insider if
you will but at this point in time the
person has complete knowledge of the
infrastructure could be in an
administrative position and then they
are trying to leverage their access to
see if they can get information or they
can compromise any stuff any of the data
so the three attacks would be the first
one blackbox where we are simulating uh
external threat a hacker sitting outside
the organization trying to gain access
the gray box is an Insider threat where
there's a regular employee who is trying
to get access to infrastructure that
they are not authorized for and then the
third audit is a white box audit where
there's an administrator who has all the
leverage all the access and the
visibility within the uh infrastructure
and then they're trying to misuse their
access to see what else they can get
from whatever access has been authorized
to them now let's look at the areas of
penetration testing where all could we
do a penetration test thus compromising
the security of the application or of
the server or of the user so first and
for formost Network Services it finds
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in the
security of the network infrastructure
so for example we have switches routers
firewalls in a network all of these are
devices that need a configuration if
they have been not correctly configured
or if they have not been correctly
secured they would leave some V
liabilities behind if we as ethical
hackers are able to identify these flaws
these misconfigurations these
vulnerabilities we could then try to
exploit them and try to gain access to
the network and devices within that
Network by uh getting access to the
network in the first place then we have
the web applications web applications
are nothing but softwares that are
developed over or deployed over a web
server and are made available over the
intranet or the internet for example uh
websites that we visit or web
applications like Facebook if you will
right so if these applications have
vulnerabilities within them we then try
to attack the web based applications and
thus try to bypass authentication or get
access to database or try to leave
information through those applications
if not then we try to attack the client
side now web application is at the
server level and is hosted by the
deployer so that's at the server side
the client side is where we as users are
using a computer with a browser and
trying to interact with the web
application now the browser and the
operating system that we are utilizing
would have its own vulnerabilities thus
identifying a client side vulnerability
and then exploiting it to either either
hack the client or then piggyback on the
client's connection and try to get
access to the server so either you could
attack the network the web application
or the client side itself or you could
attack wireless networks this test would
examine all the wireless devices which
are used in a corporation most of the
wireless would have laptops smartphones
tablets faets all of those connected to
them if you're able to access any of
these devices through the wireless it
would help you gain access to other
devices on the wireless as well and then
social engineering so this is where
you're trying to attack humans you're
tricking an employee of a corporation to
reveal some confidential information
knowingly or unknowingly by tricking
them with the fake mails or fake
websites or malicious emails that you
have sent to them uh which they have
failed to recognize as malicious and
they click on it thus getting victimized
social engineering attacks are always uh
successful because of the gullibility of
humans empathy sympathy humans basically
have emotions emotions can be toyed with
and then taken advantage off if the
person is not careful enough for example
the most common social engineering
attack that we see is the Nigerian fraud
where we receive an email that someone
somewhere has died and has left a huge
estate behind a few hundred million doar
and we have been identified as the
person through whom they want to
transfer the money to a foreign land to
save on taxes what are the chances of
that happening on a daily basis right
how many princes are there so that's
something that we do not verify it's
just the I guess the greed if you will
of striking it rich quickly that makes
us believe these kind of emails uh we
have also received emails of lottery
tickets that we have won over a period
of time without even having bought a
lottery ticket so if you haven't bought
one what did you win but we don't ask
these questions we just get excited
about the amount of money that we have
won and then we try to bet on our luck
and try to see if that uh email is going
to fructify or is it just another scam
so social engineering attacks are dime a
dozen these days and we need to be very
careful on what we trust on the internet
let's look at the penetration testing
tools there are hundreds and thousands
of tools out there most of these have
been concised and collected together and
hosted on a operating system known as KH
Linux that we have talked about earlier
now the predecessor to KH Linux was
backtrack backtrack is no longer
continued it has been discontinued and K
Linux has taken uh the place of
backtrack within which are all the tools
that you see on your screen metas sploit
is one of the most favorite penetration
testing tools of hackers and ethical
hackers uh there are a lot of inbuilt
exploits over there and we'll be doing a
demo at the end of the session on this
nmap is the information gathering tool
which will scan for live devices scan
for open ports protocols and services
beef would be an application testing
tool that would help us uh find exploits
within applications nessus vulnerability
scanner is a network and a host based
scanner that would help you identify
vulnerabilities within such hosts y
shock is a network sniffer which allows
you to capture Network packets and and
analyze them to see if there are there
is any information worth capturing
within those packets SQL map is a
automated tool used for SQL injection
attacks so you don't even have to craft
your queries for SQL injection it will
be done by the SQL map tool you just
need to identify whatever is possible
through the queries that this SQL is
going to create and then based on the
activity that you've identified you just
need to redefine your search parameters
to get access to the database we'll be
doing a demo on SQL map or SQL map as
well and then there is John the Ripper
John the Ripper is a tool that is used
for password cracking so dictionary
attacks Brute Force attacks are done
using John the Ripper what is a
dictionary attack a dictionary attack is
an attack where we create list of all
probable passwords store them in a txt
file and run that list against the
password tool to see if any of those
passwords are going to match a Brute
Force attack is trying the same attack
but with every permutation and
combination of the alphabet that we have
and we're going to try to figure out uh
if we are able to crack the password at
all so these are just some of the tools
for every tool there are another
supporting 100 tools or more than that
uh like for NS vulnerability scanner
you'll have Callis vulnerability scanner
you have uh GFI lanard and there are
other lots of other softwares out there
but these are some of the most commonly
utilized tools let's look at the metas
attack Metasploit is a framework of
penetration testing that makes hacking
very simple you just need to know how to
utilize the tool you need to identify
the vulnerability associate with a
particular exploit and then run the
exploit on metas sploit we'll be demoing
this during the Practical so there are
active exploits and passive exploits in
active exploits exploits a specific
computer runs until execution and then
exits uses brute force and exits when an
error occurs in a passive exploit these
exploits wait for incoming requests and
exploit them as soon as they connect
they can also be used in conjunction
with emails and web browsers so in pacif
exploits we create a payload we uh like
a reverse connection payload we send it
to the victim once the victim installs
that software the machine will then
initiate a connection to us our machine
will be in a listen mode and then we
will once the software is executed at
the end we would then try to connect and
exploit that particular vulnerability
this is the uh practical that we'll be
doing on Metasploit so let's move on
with the demos and then we'll see uh
what we can discuss amongst them all
right let's have a look at some of the
demos that we have had uh talked about
in the ethical hacking and penetration
testing module we are going to look at
three different demos the first one is
going to be a SQL injection attack that
we're going to perform on this tool that
we have the second one is a password
cracking attack on Windows 7 and the
third one is a meter based or a metas
sploid based shell shock attack on a
Linux based web server so let's get
cracking I've powered on this virtual
machine uh which is the ovas broken web
application it is a tool that is
provided for people who want to enhance
their skill and they can practice uh how
to do these attacks in a legal manner so
we are going to go to this site I'm just
going to open up my browser the IP
address is 7113 to and that's the ovas
broken web application that we want to
utilize we're going to head off to mutil
Day 2 and we are going to look at a SQL
injection attack where we want to bypass
authentication now this takes us to the
login screen so we can just try our luck
here and see that the authentication
mechanism works the account does not
exist so the username and password that
we have supplied is not the correct one
so we want to ensure that there's a SQL
database and uh we can uh try to attack
it and see uh if we can bypass the
authentication now uh what we want to do
is we want to create a SQL based
malformed query that can give us a
different output so I'm just going to
type in a single quote over here and
type login and you can see that this is
now suddenly recognized as a operator
and there's a error that is is given out
compared to the login that we tried uh
earlier when we used a proper text based
login mechanism it gave us the account
does not exist but here the single code
gave us a error and it shows us how SQL
works this is the query that we had
created now in the trainings that you
have for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what these queries are
all about how the syntax works here we
just going to see if we can create a
malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is uh
create the query over here and we're
going to give it a comparison so we're
going to give it R 1 equal 1 space
hyphen hyphen space and if you now click
login you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database and Oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
at a demo this is how a SQL injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query worked wonders where it
allowed us to bypass authentication so
it also depends on what kind of a page I
am and what query would be accepted at
this point in time so here application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we
calling upon when we connected to a
particular particular page now this is a
user lookup function right so again here
we try the same method test test that's
not going to work authentication error
bad user or password and if we type in
the same query over here single quote or
and give it a condition single quote or
one equals 1 space hyphen hyen space now
here it is not going to log Us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it will
instead give us a dump of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the usernames and passwords coming in
that are stored in the user lookup field
so this is where the understanding comes
in of which query to create at what page
we are depending upon the function that
is being called right so that's the SQL
uh injection attack that we wanted to
look at let's move on to password
cracking now this is a Windows 7 machine
that we have I'm just going to do a very
basic password tracking example we're
just going to log in now here the
assumption is that we are able to log in
we have access to a computer and we want
to check out other users who are using
this computer computer and see if we can
find out their passwords so that uh we
can log in as a different user steal
data if required and we wouldn't be to
blame if there are any locks that are
created so here we've got a tool called
can and aable that is installed right
here now I'm already an administrator on
this machine I'm checking out other
administrators who share the same
privileges or any other user who may be
on this system whose password I can
crack and thus I would be able to get
access through their account and then do
any malicious activity right so this
allows me to go into a cracker tool and
it allows me to enumerate this machine
and identify all the users and passwords
that are there in this particular
machine right so I'm just going to click
on the plus sign and I'm going to import
uh hashes from a local system so where
are these files stored where does
Windows store its passwords in what
format are they stored and what this
tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as a
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click on
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users or hacker admin test the
one that we are logged in as and then
there's a user called virus as well and
you can see that this is the hash value
of the password that is being utilized
now there's a particular format uh for a
hash value for Windows and how it stores
but once we have these hash values let's
say if I want to crack this password
there are various attacks that we can do
for example example a dictionary based
attack or a Brute Force attack let's try
a Brute Force attack right ntlm is the
hashing mechanism that is used by
windows so we're going to try to create
an LTM hash attack and here we're going
to use a predetermined rule set for
example we are not sure what characters
are being utilized over here so we just
create an attack like this using all
characters and uh lowercase a through
Zed uppercase a through Zed numeric 0- 9
and all the special characters let's say
the password is between 7 and 16
characters and this is the character set
that we want to try the Brute Force
attack on what is a root Force attack it
is an attack where the computer is going
to try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so if we click Start
it's going to start with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character and you can
see the time is going to be phenomenal
over here so it's not necessary that
this attack would be viable it will be
100% successful given the time frame
however the time frame is huge enough
for this attack to become a little bit
redundant there are other attacks that
we can do which can easily identify this
data for us as well but that is
something that we will look on in future
videos so that's how we can get access
to users and passwords uh there are
different mechanisms where let's say we
don't have login access then what are we
going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remove Ely
access a machine and then try to get the
same access and that is what we going to
try to do in the next demo on a Linux
machine so what we are doing in a Linux
machine could also be doable on the
Windows machine with a different exploit
so what I'm going to do is this is the
Linux web server that I have that I'm
going to power on I'm going to use a k
Linux machine to hack that device and
I'm going to just power off my Windows 7
machine give it a minute till it boots
up now this is also a demo machine that
we have which has its own preconfigured
vulnerabilities so here we've got
something from the pentesters lab uh and
has a shell shock vulnerability imp
implemented inside shell shock
vulnerability affects Linux Mac and Unix
based operating systems for a particular
version of The Bash shell bash is the
bone again shell which is the command
line interface in these operating
systems so what we're trying to do here
is we're going to use the Kali Linux
machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we're going to use metas sploit to
attack this machine now the first and
foremost thing is we want to identify
the IP address we have no idea what the
IP address is we are in the same subnet
so we are assuming that we're able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called zenmap I'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my IP address is and my IP address is
this with a subnet mask of 255 255
255.0.0.0 we doing a pink Swip over here
to identify which machines are live in a
minute we'll get all the IP addresses
71.1 2 133 254 and 128 we know that we
are 128 at this point in time uh 254 is
the DHCP server so we assuming that 133
is the machine that we want to look at
and let's then try to see if we can scan
that machine 133 and we're going to do
an intense scan to find out which ports
are open what services are running over
there and if it is whether the the
pentest machine that we were looking for
you can see of the start Port 22 and
Port 80 and somewhere here it's going to
give us the ports that are open and the
details about those ports and somewhere
here it will tell us that this is the
pentester lab machine that we wanted
which is correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this what
we're going to do is I'm going to use
another GUI based tool called Sparta
which I can just find out from here
Sparta uses two tools in the background
uh nmap tool and a tool called ncto so
we just going to start scanning 192 168
71133 was the IP address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information there we are that's the ncto
tool coming in scanning on Port 80 which
is uh which means that it's a web server
using HTTP it tells us it's an Apache HT
httpd
2221 and that gives us the 22 port
number as well if we head over to the
tab of Nick or let's look at the
screenshot first this is what the
website would be looking like and ncto
gives us the options over here it tells
us that there is a vulnerability over
here for shell shock and this is the
path where the vulnerability is going to
exist so what we going to do we go back
to the command line sorry we open up a
new one minimize all these other windows
and we are going to open up Metasploit
Metasploit is a penetration testing tool
that is used by most hackers and ethical
hackers to test applications and test uh
existing exploits and vulnerabilities so
just give it a minute till it starts you
can see there are already around 1,700
exploits right here uh we're going to
see all those exploits with these
commands there we are sorry for the typo
and it will just give us a list of all
the exploits that are stored in metas
spit in this version so all of these are
windows based if we scroll up we will be
looking at other vulnerabilities as well
or exploits the unique SP exploits Linx
OSX multi exploits and we're looking for
a exploit for um multi- based Apache or
HTTP let's go up uh let's look at so
this is the one that we're looking for
Apache mod CGI bash environmental
executable so what we're going to do is
we're just going to copy it go back to
the bottom say use exploit and paste the
one that we wanted press enter say show
options so it will ask us to configure
this I'm just going to configure it
based on the knowledge that we have set
our host which is the remote host the
victim's machine so we put in the IP
address it asks us for the Target URI so
that's the path that we saw set Target
URI to CGI hyphen bin SL status enter
now with the exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want so we say show
payloads and it will give us a list of
all the compatible payloads with this
exploit and we want to create a reverse
TCP connection which is this so we know
it's it's a Linux operating system we
want this uh payload to be set so set
payload press enter that's the payload
coming in show options now that we have
set the payload this is the options for
the exploit and now we want to set our
options for the payloads as well so we
are creating a reverse TCP connection
which means we are remotely executing
code at the victim side and making the
victim connect back to our machine which
means we need to set up a listener so I
need to put my IP address over here set
local host or lhost 192
16871 1228 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start this attack you can see that
it has created a MPR session at the
victim site and it has opened up a
session so if I do a PWD now PWD is a
Linux command for present working
directory and it will show us that we'll
connected to v dub dubdub CGI hyphen bin
do an LS it will list all the files
that's the status file over there do a
CD backlash it will take us to the root
of this machine if you're an aspiring
cyber security professional looking for
online training and certifications from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply Larch postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice for more details you
can use the link mentioned in the Des
description box below with the next
generation of Internet exchanges focused
on maximum privacy and security a
variety of ways have been enforced to
maintain them as such censorship has
been shifted from the streets to the
digital domain it forces the standard
citizen to derive alternative ways to
maintain anonymity major weapon in this
battle for privacy and security is the T
browser an independent browser meant to
browse the internet while reing
information through the Tor Network it
serves as a meaningful alternative to
the the standard internet browsing
habits to better understand the purpose
of this browser and suchar we must learn
about the work of the T Network
featuring its own routing protocol the
to browser is an easy way to maintain
anonymity while browsing without
emptying one's wallet let's take a look
at the topics to be covered
today we start at the explanation of
what is the T Network and its
significance in the working of the T
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
tour directories in order to circumvent
government
censorship moving on we learn a few
features of the T browser and the
distinct advantages the tour Network
provides next we learn the difference
between using a VPN and a tour to
anonymize internet usage and finally we
have a live demonstration of the Tor
Browser anonymization features in
action let's move on to learning about
the Tor
Network
T short for the onion router it's an
open-source privacy Network that permits
users to browse the web anonymously the
T was initially developed and solely
used by the US Navy to protect sensitive
government Communications before the
network was made publicly available the
digital era has disrupted the
traditional way of doing things in every
sector of the economy the rapid Rising
development and innovation of digital
products has given way to frequent data
breaches and cyber thefts in response
consumers are increasingly opting for
products that offer data privacy and
cyber security T is one such underground
Network that was implemented for the
purpose of protecting users identities
the to network is one example of the
many emerging technologies that attempt
to fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the to network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed pass to the user requester Final
Destination these random users are
volunteer devices which are called as
nodes or relays the T Network disguises
your identity by encrypting the traffic
and moving it across different to relays
within the network the Tor Network uses
an onion routing technique for
transmitting data hence the original
name of onion router to operate within
the T Network a user has to install the
T browser any address or information
requested using the browser is is
transmitted through the T Network it has
its own feature set which we will be
covering over later in this
video as we discussed already the data
passing through the T Network must
follow a unique protocol known as The
Onion routing protocol let us learn more
about its unique
characteristics in our normal Network
usage the data is transmitted directly
the sender has data package to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind however
since the data can easily be captured
while being transmitted the security of
this exchange is not very reliable
moreover it becomes very easy to trace
the origin of such requests on many
occasions websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the ISP this is possible since the ISP
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the
Internet however in the onion routing
protocol things take a longer route we
have a sender with the to browser
installed on the client system the
network sends the information to node
one's IP address which encrypts the
information and passes it on to node 2's
address which performs another
encryption and passes it on to node 3
address this this is the last address
which is also known as the exit node
this last node decrypts the encrypted
data and finally relays the request to
the Final Destination which can be
another device or a server end this
final address thinks the request came
from the exit node and grants access to
it the encryption process across
multiple computers repeats itself from
the exit node to the original user the
to network of Fates user IP addresses
from unwanted surveillance by keeping
the users's request untraceable with
multiple servers touching the data it
makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious
attackers now that we understand the way
T Works let us learn more about the T
browser the T browser was developed by a
nonprofit organization as a part of the
Tor project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced the T browser is a
browser Fork from the popular Firefox
that anonymizes your web traffic using
the T network if you're in investigating
a competitor researching an opposing
litigant in a legal dispute or just
think it's creepy for your ISP or the
government to know what websites you
visit the to browser might be the right
solution before the to browser were
developed using that Network to maintain
anonymity was a huge task for everyday
consumers starting from the setup to the
usage the entire process demanded a lot
of knowledge and practice the to browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers inour and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange a major feature of the Tor
Browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is closed every new
launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the to network
is the availability of onion links only
a small portion of the worldwide web is
available to the general public we have
the Deep Web that contains links that
are not not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these
onion websites which are only available
within the T Network onion is a special
used top level domain which designates
an anonymous onion service which is also
known as a hidden service similar to The
Links of the Deep Web these onion links
provide services like online shopping
cryptocurrency and many other products
not available in the consumer Internet
space often being considered as a Haven
for illegal activities and sales onion
links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by
authorities browsing the web over tour
is slower than the clear net due to the
multiple layers of
encryption some web services also block
to users to browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously journalist
and residents around the world have
embraced t as a Cornerstone of democracy
and researchers are hard at work at
improving TS anonymity
properties let us take a look at some of
the advantages of using the T browser
over standard web
browsers the highlight of using the T
browser is to maintain anonymity over
the Internet the cause for such requests
can differ from person to person but all
of these concern are answered by the to
network doubting the information via
multiple node and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track of usage
data the entire to project is designed
to be completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by Third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under AU authoritarian
regimes have difficulty in getting the
word out regarding the situation since
the onion routing protocol transfers
data between multiple servers of random
countries the domains being blocked
become available when used via T usage
of these encryption messaging platforms
is easily enforced using the T browser
which otherwise would have been a
difficult task under oppressive
circumstances many people believe that a
VPN offers the same benefits as the top
browser let's put both of them to the
test and see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference T is completely free and open
source all of the code for the browser
and the network can be audited and has
been cleared for security concerns when
it comes to VPN there are many different
brands which have open source clients
but the same cannot be said for their
counterparts some have partly open
source while some have completely locked
up their code so that they cannot be
stolen
further moving M on T has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always be
more than two once the data is passed
from the cender it goes through all of
those delay points while in the case of
a VPN the connection is made from the
client device to the VPN server and then
to the requested destination there is no
other IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one: one
between the client and a VPN
as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes
through similarly the multi-layer
encryption of T is consistent if you use
T browser every single request passes
through the same layer of encryption and
follows the same routing protocol in the
case of a VPN different companies offer
different levels of encryption some have
multihop some prefer a single onet toone
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more
variable finally the nodes and relays
being used in the tour Network are
volunteer there is no company holding
over them so jurisdiction becomes
relatively straightforward when in in
the case of vpns many such vpns are
hosted by adware companies or are being
monitored by Central governments to note
the usage information
now that we have a better understanding
of the T browser and its routing let us
take a look at how the T browser can
anonymize and protect our internet
usage on opening up the tour browser for
the first time this is the page that
you're going to be welcomed with you
have the option of connecting to the to
network before we start our
browsing so let's press
connect and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's let's check my
current location on Google
Chrome currently is showing as Navi
Mumbai in
Maharashtra if you check the same link
on the T browser we should get a
different
address now every link that we open in
the T browser will be little delayed and
the speed will be hampered because of
the multiple layers of encryption like
we discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works there is no VPN configured there
is no proxy attached it's straight up
the outof the Box settings that come
inbuilt with the tour browser similarly
we have an option of cleaning up the
data let's say if you want to refresh
your location and you want to use a
different ID for the next browsing
session if you just restart it once and
we can have to check it
again
we should be seeing a different country
this
time as you can see we have Netherlands
right now so this is how you can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that
you cannot be tracked when in browsing
the internet like we discussed we have
some onion links that can only be used
on the tour
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the Tor
Browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the tour
Network this is kind of an alternative
Wikipedia website where we can find
articles to read and more information to
learn similarly we have another onion
link over
here which is once again available only
for the toall
browser
now these kind of delays are expected
but they are a valid compromise because
they maintain the anonymity that many
people desire similarly we have found a
hidden wallet which is a cryptocurrency
wallet which is specifically for dark
web
members this operates over the T Network
and this is used by mostly journalists
and people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the Tor Network are almost
impossible to track therefore these kind
of cryptocurrency wallets are very big
on the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available Jude is waiting at the airport
to hop on her flight back home when she
realizes that she missed making an
important Bank payment she connects her
laptop to the public Wi-Fi at the
airport and goes ahead to carry out the
bank transaction everything goes well
and June completes her
transaction after a couple of days she
was wiped off her feet when she learned
that her bank account was subjected to a
Cyber attack and a hefty amount was
wiped from her account after getting in
touch with the bank Authority she
learned that her account was hacked at
the airport she then realized that the
public Wi-Fi she used might have caused
her this trouble Jude wishes that had
her bank transfer escaped the Hacker's
eyes she would not have been a victim of
a Cyber attack Bank official advis her
to use a VPN for future transactions
especially when connecting to an open or
public network like most of us Jude had
come across the term VPN several times
but didn't know much about it and little
did she think that the repercussions of
not using a VPN would be this bad let's
understand how the hacker would have
exploited Jude's transaction in the
absence of a VPN in this process judee's
computer first connects to the internet
service provider ISP
which provides access to the internet
she sends her details to the bank server
using her IP address Internet Protocol
address or IP address is a unique
address that recognizes a particular
device be it a laptop or a smartphone on
the internet when these details pass
through the public network the hacker
who passively watches the network
traffic intercepts it this is a passive
Cyber attack where the hacker collects
jud's Bank details without being
detected more often or not in such an
attack payment information is likely to
be stolen the targeted data here are the
victim's username passwords and other
personal information such an unsecured
connection exposed Jude's IP address and
Bank details to the hacker when it
passed through the public network so
would Jude have been able to secure her
transaction with the help of a VPN well
yes picture Jude's Bank transaction to
be happening in a tunnel that is
invisible to the hacker in such a case
the hacker will not be able to spot a
transaction and that is precisely what a
VPN does a virtual private Network more
often known as VPN creates a secure
tunnel between your device and the
internet for using a VPN judee's First
Step would be to install software-based
technology known as the VPN client on
her laptop or smartphone that would let
her establish a secure connection the
VPN client connects to the Wi-Fi and
then to the
ISP here the VPN client encrypts jud's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure next
the VPN client establishes a VPN tunnel
within the public network that connects
to the VPN server the VPN tunnel
protects jud's information from being
intercepted by the hacker judee's IP
address and actual location are changed
at the VPN server to enable a private
and secure connection finally the VPN
server connects to Jude's Bank server in
the last step where the encrypted
message is
decrypted this way judee's original IP
address is hidden by the VPN and the VPN
tunnel protects her data from being
hacked this explains how VPN makes your
data Anonymous and secure when it passes
through the public network and the
difference between a normal connection
and a VPN connection after learning
about this Jude was certain that she
should start using a VPN to carry out
her online transactions in the future
this is also appc to each one of us even
if you work remotely or connect to
public Wi-Fi using a VPN is the safest
option in addition to providing a secure
encrypted data transfer vpns are also
used to disguise your whereabouts and
give you access to Regional web content
VPN servers act as proxies on the
internet this way your actual location
cannot be established VPN enables you to
spoof your location and switch to a
server to another country and thereby
change your location for example by
doing so you can watch any content on
Netflix that might be unavailable for
your region imagine our houses without a
fence or boundary wall this would make
our properly easy accessible to
trespassers and robbers and place our
homes at Great risk right hence fencing
our property helps safeguarded and keeps
trespassers at Bay similarly imagine our
computers and networks without
protection this would increase the
probability of hackers infiltrating our
networks to overcome this challenge just
like how boundary walls protect our
houses a virtual wall helps Safeguard
and secure our devices from Intruders
and such a wall is known as a firewall
firewalls are security devices that
filter the incoming and outgoing traffic
within a private Network for example if
you were to visit your friend who lives
in a gated community you would First
Take permission from the security guard
the security guard would check with your
friend if you should be allowed to entry
or not if all is well your access is
granted on the other hand the security
guard would not Grant permission to a
trespasser looking to enter the same
premises here the entry access depends
solely on your friend the resident's
discretion the role of the security
guard in this case is similar to that of
a firewall the firewall works like a
gatekeeper at your computer's entry
point which only welcomes incoming
traffic that it has been configured to
accept firewalls filter the network
traffic within your network and analyzes
which traffic should be allowed or
restricted based on a set of rules in
order to spot and prevent cyber attacks
your computer communicates with the
internet in the form of network packets
that hold details like the source
address destination address and
information these Network packets enter
your computer through ports the firewall
works on a set of rules based on the
details of these Network packets like
their Source address a destination
address content and port numbers only
trusted traffic sources or IP addresses
are allowed to enter your network when
you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your network this
is when a firewall comes to your Rescue
by acting as a barrier between your
computer and the internet the firewall
rejects the malicious data package and
thus protects your network from hackers
on the other hand traffic from trusted
websites is allowed access to your
network
this way the firewall carries out quick
assessments to detect malware and other
suspicious activities thereby protecting
your network from being susceptible to a
Cyber attack firewalls can either be
Hardware or software software firewalls
are programs installed on each computer
this is also called a host firewall
meanwhile Hardware firewalls are
equipments that are established between
the Gateway and your network linky
routers are a good example of a hardware
firewall besides this there are other
types of firewalls designed based on
their traffic filtering methods
structure and functionality the firewall
that compares each outgoing and incoming
Network packet to a set of established
rules such as the allowed IP addresses
IP protocols port number and other
aspects of the packet is known as a
packet filtering firewall if the
incoming Network traffic is not for the
predefined rules that traffic is blocked
a variant of the packet filtering
firewall is the stateful inspection
firewall
these types of firewalls not only
examine each Network packet but also
checks whether or not that Network
packet is part of an established network
connection such firewalls are also
referred to as Dynamic packet filtering
firewalls our next type of firewall is
called a proxy firewall this draws close
comparison to how you give proxy
attendance for a friend like how you
take the authority to represent your
friend the proxy firewall pretends to be
you and interacts with the internet they
come between you and the internet and
thereby prevents direct connections this
protects your device's identity and
keeps the network safe from potential
attacks only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you they're
also known as application Level Gateway
a firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institutions and offices to restrict
users access to certain websites or
applications it is used to avoid access
to unauthorized content the year was
1971 an engineer named Bob thomet at BBN
an American research and development
company later acquired by Reon created
the world's first virus proof of concept
DED the creeper although credited and
referenced by various entities as the
world's first computer virus the creeper
actually exhibited the behavior of a w i
the creeper and catch me if you can this
is what the virus said and the world was
never the same with over 12 types of
malves and over 100 types of viruses
lurking around the network channels of
the internet waiting to curb innocent
users and exploit vulnerabilities the
21st century saw a tremendous growth in
cyber crimes and so did the need and
demand for cyber Security Experts hello
everyone and welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel in this video we'll take
a look at malw the bread and butter of
thousands of hackers GL and what are its
various types we'll dive deep into
understanding how each of these malw
function and how they differentiate from
each other but before that if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
attractive then subscribe to our YouTube
channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily also press the Bell icon
to never miss any updates from Simply
learn as we know the demand for cyber
security personnels is skyrocketing so
if you want to master the field of cyber
security then simply learn postgraduate
program in cyber security in
collaboration with MIT is clearly the
right choice for you this post-graduate
program in cyber security is designed to
equip you with the skills required to
become an expert in the rapidly growing
field of cyber security this cyber
security program aims to help you stay
ahead of the latest cyber security
Trends key features of this program
simply learns post-graduate certificate
master classes from MIT faculty
featuring modules from mitc and EC
Council access to C kit 25 plus Hands-On
projects and many more this cyber
security certification program begins
with introductory level skills and then
progresses to advanc cyber security
Technologies this program covers all the
essential skills you will need to become
an expert in the field of cyber security
cyber security is one of the top
concerns of businesses today in an
industry from securing data to
anticipating cyber attacks and placing
enterprise-wide safeguards to prevent
them employers worldwide are
increasingly looking for qualified cyber
security profession professionals to
join them so what are you waiting for
find the course link mentioned in the
description box below and enroll today
so without any further delay let's jump
directly onto our topic for the day so
let's start with what is malware malware
is a short form for malicious software
and it's like a sneaky digital Intruder
that infiltrates your device without
permission it's created by cyber
criminals who want to disrupt damage or
gain unauthorized access to your
personal information financial data or
even control your device remotely think
of malware as a digital bully that's up
to no good so let's understand how does
a malware work step one intrusion
malware sneaks into your device through
various entry points like malicious
email attachments infected websites
software vulnerabilities or even through
removable storage devices like USB
drives step two is execution once inside
the malware starts executing its
malicious code it may install additional
files modify system settings or create
hidden processes in the background to
evade detection step three is
persistence to maintain control over
your device malware often tries to
establish persistence it may create
registered entries modify startup
settings or hide in system folders
ensuring it launches every time you boot
up your device next step is exploitation
malware takes advantage of
vulnerabilities in your operating system
applications on network to spread its
reach it may exploit security weaknesses
to propagate across networks infect
other devices or steel sensitive
information the step five is malicious
activities now that the malware has
settled in it carries out its intended
actions depending on its type this could
include stealing personal information
capturing keystrokes encrypting files
displaying unwanted ads or even
hijacking your device for cyber
criminals remote control
the next step is concealment malware
often employs techniques to hide its
presence and avoid detection it may use
rootkit technology to hide its files and
processes employ anti-analysis measures
or encrypt its communication with
command and control servers to evade
security measures the last step is
damage or profit ultimately malware aims
to achieve its malicious objective it
may cause damage to your system
compromise your privacy steal Financial
information or create opportunities for
cyber criminals to profit have you ever
wondered how it feels to be a cyber
security expert after gaining a
certification so let's take a minute to
hear it out from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
career after taking the cyber security
course hi I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old
and last year I upskilled with simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
it sector and various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors I worked with many companies
before a security analyst and architect
on a contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with infosis as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course but first foremost up
been a learner be a learner first now
that we have a good idea of how does a
malware work let's understand the
different types of malware more than 12
types of malwares are present in the
world today and each of them is
threatening to different extent so let's
discuss some of the most common and
hazardous malwares the first is virus a
classic Troublemaker that attaches
itself to a program or file replicating
and spreading across your system it can
corrupt or destroy data and even render
your device useless the second one is
warm a sneaky creature that replicates
itself and spreads across networks
causing congestion and slowing down
systems it can also exploit
vulnerabilities to gain unauthorized
exess the next one is troan hor inspired
by the ancient Greek tale this malware
disguises itself as a legitimate
software tricking you into installing it
once inside it opens a back door giving
cyber criminals remote control over your
device the next is ransomware this
villainous malware holds your data
hostage by encrypting it the Cyber
criminals then demand a ransom to
restore access leaving you feel like a
character in a digital hostage situation
next is spyware a nosy little malware
that secretly monitors your activities
collecting sensitive informations like
password browsing habits and even key
strokes talk about an invasion of
privacy
the next one is
atwar an annoying Troublemaker that
bombards you with unwanted
advertisements popups and redirects it's
like a clingy digital salesperson that
never takes no for an answer so those
are some of the truly menacing types of
malware but knowledge is power so how
can we protect ourselves from these
digital
villains the first step is keep your
software up to date regularly update
your operating system antivirus software
and applications these updates often
include security pages to fix
vulnerabilities use strong and unique
passwords avoid using common or easy to
guess passwords opt for a combination of
letters numbers and symbols next is be
cautious while you are online avoid
clicking on suspicious links downloading
files from untrustworthy sources or
opening email attachments from unknown
senders stay vigilant next one is
install reputable antivirus
software invest in reliable antivirus
software that can detect and remove
malwares last is backup your data
regularly back up your important files
and data to an external hard drive or
cloud storage that way even if your
device gets infected you can restore
your files anytime so I guess you guys
must have got a good idea about what is
a malware and how to stay safe from a
malware now you may be wondering what is
SQL injection well let us explain SQL
injection is a serious vulnerability
affecting web applications where
attackers can execute unintended code on
a server by injecting malicious SQL
commands into a database query if
successful an attacker can gain
unauthorized access to sensitive data or
even modify it so if you are a web
developer this is something you must
take seriously but don't worry in this
video we will explain how seal injection
works why it's so dangerous and how you
can protect your application from it so
be sure to watch until the end to learn
how to safeguard your apps from this
threat before we begin if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply lears postgraduate program in
cyber security that is in collaboration
with the modules from MIT schwarzman
College of Engineering and the course
link is mentioned in the description box
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete beor
you of the program being offered and if
these are the types of videos you would
like to watch then hit the Subscribe
button like and press the Bell icon to
never miss on any update and here we go
and now we'll see the agenda for our
tutorial starting with we'll first see
what is SQL injection then we'll see how
does a SQL injection attack work then
we'll see what are types of SQL
injection tags and then we'll see the
detection and prevention of SQL
injection attacks then we'll see some
real life examples that happen with the
SQL injections and then we'll have a
overview of impact of SQL injection
attacks now we'll start with what is SQL
injection SQL injection is a technique
used by attackers to manipulate a web
application's database queries by
injecting malicious SQL code into input
Fields attackers can execute
unauthorized commands and potentially
gain access to sensitive information SQL
injection attacks primarily Target web
applications that use SQL databases such
as MySQL Oracle or Microsoft SQL server
and now we will see how does a SQL
injection attack work so to understand
how a SQL injection attack Works let's
consider how a typical SQL query
functions queries are used to retrieve
or modify data from a database attackers
exploit vulnerable input Fields by
injecting malicious SQL code that alters
the intended behavior of the query and
attackers first study the targeted
database to understand its structure and
behavior then they craft a SQL query
that the server interprets as a
legitimate command for example or 1al to
1 that is a queries input field an
attacker can bypass authentication and
gain access unauthorized access and SQL
injection and TXS can also be used to
delete data manipulate records or
retrieve information from multiple
database tables using techniques like
error based injection Union based
attacks or inferential SQL injection now
we'll see an example to understand this
concept more so consider a website that
has search feature where users can
search for products by entering keywords
the website uses a SQL database to store
product information in a secure scenario
the website would take the user's input
sanitize it and construct a SQL query to
fetch the relevant products for example
the query might look like this that that
is Select star from products with name
like and the entered keyword what they
want to search so this query retrieves
products whose names contain the entered
keyword however if the website is
vulnerable to SQL injection an attacker
can manipulate the input to execute
medicia SQL statements let's say the
attacker wants to retrieve all products
from the database regardless of the
entered keyword in the search field they
entered or 1 equal to 1 hyphen hyphen
the input manipulates the SQL query and
this query becomes this that is Select
star from products we name like m% and
then or 1 equal to 1 hyphen hyph percent
in this case the attacker uses the
single code to close the existing string
followed by or 1al to 1 hyph hyph to
inject a new condition that is always
true the semicolon is used to terminate
the previous statement and the double
hyphens are used to comment out the
remaining portion of the original query
as a result the modified query
effectively becomes that you can see on
the screen and the condition 1 equal to
1 is always true so the query retrieves
all products from the database
regardless of the keyword and this
example demonstrates how an attacker can
exploit a vulnerable SQL injection point
to modify the SQL queries logic and
retrieve unintended data remember this
example is simplified for educational
purposes and real world SQL injection
attacks can be more sophisticated it's
crucial to secure web applications
against SQL injection vulnerabilities to
prevent unauthorized access and data
Brides now we'll see types of SQL
injection attacks so there are different
types of SQL injection attacks that
attackers can employ let's explore a few
of them the first we'll explore is
inband SQL I I is injection here that is
inband SQL injection so this type
includes error based and Union based
attacks where attackers use the same
check channel to laun gench and collect
the results and the next is inferential
SQL injection that is also known as
blind SQL injection this type involves
sending data payloads to the database
server to observe its response without
directly seeing the results it can be
either Boolean based or time based and
the next is out of band SQL injection in
cases where inband SQL injection is not
possible attackers leverage other
channels such as DNS or HTTP request to
retrieve data from the dat database now
we'll see detecting and preventing SQL
injection attacks so detecting and
preventing SQL injection attacks is
crucial to safeguarding web applications
here are some preventive measures so the
first measure is train employees on
preventive methods that is educate your
it teams including developers and system
administrators on SQL injection attack
vectors and prevention techniques next
we could do is Implement input
validation and parameterized queries
validate and filter user input using an
allow list approach and use
parameterized queries or prepared
statements to separate SQL code from
user input that will not allow any
malicious hacker to enter any SQL code
into the input method and the next is
regular security scans perform regular
security scans to identify and address
potential vulnerabilities in web
applications and the next is keep
software up to date that is ensure that
old software including databases and
programming languages are regularly
updated to include the latest security
patches and protections against SQL
injection and now we'll see some real
life examples of SQL injection attacks
so let's take a look at some real life
examples the first is Tesla
vulnerability in 2014 security
researchers discovered a SQL injection
vulnerability on Tesla's website which
allowed attackers to gain administrative
privileges and access user data this was
one of the SQL injection attacks and the
next was fortnite vulnerability in 2019
a SQL injection vulnerability was found
in fortnite that could have enabled
attackers to access user accounts the
vulnerability was promptly patched and
the next was Cisco vulnerability in 2018
a SQL injection vulnerability in Cisco
Prime license manager granted attackers
shell access to computers with the
installed license management system
Cisco address the issue promptly and
last not the least we'll see the impact
of SQL injection attacks so the impact
of SQL injection attacks can be
devastating for businesses the first
could be the unauthorized access to
sensitive information and resources and
the next is potential data breaches and
exposure to confidential data and the
next is data manipulation or deletion
and the next is Network infiltration and
system compromise and the next is loss
of customer trust and and decreased
revenue and the last is reputational
damage and long-term consequences for
the business and that wraps up our
discussion on SQL injection it's crucial
for businesses and developers to be
aware of this vulnerability and take
necessary precautions to prevent attacks
stay vigilant keep your software up to
date and educate yourself and your team
on best practices for web application
security Jane is relaxing at home when
she receives an email from a bank that
asks her to update her credit card p in
the next 24 hours as a security measure
judging the severity of the message Jane
follows the link provided in the email
on delivering her current credit card
pin and the supposedly updated one the
website became unresponsive which
prompted her to try sometime later
however after a couple of hours she
noticed a significant purchase from a
random website on that same credit card
which she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with a malicious link that
entailed credit card fraud this is a
classic example of a fishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted Source its basic
purpose is to trick the victim into
revealing sensitive information like
passwords and payment information it's
based on the word fishing which works on
the concept of baits if a supposed
victim catches the bait the attack can
go ahead which in our case makes Jane
the fish and the fishing emails the bait
if Jane never opened the malitia link or
was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively
ineffective but how does the hacker gain
access to these credentials a fishing
attack starts with a fraudulent message
which can be transmitted via email or
chat applications even using SMS
conversations to improve impersonate
legitimate sources is known as smishing
which is a specific category of fishing
attacks irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns where an identical
fishing mail is sent to thousands of
users the rate of success is relatively
low but never zero between 2013 and 2015
corporate giants like Facebook and
Google were tricked off of $100 million
due to an extensive fishing campaign
where a known common associate was
impersonated by the hackers
apart from credit access some of these
campaigns Target the victim device and
install malware when clicked on the
malicious links which can later function
as a botn net or Target for ransomware
attacks there is no single formula for
there are multiple categories of fishing
attacks the issue with Jane where the
hacker stole her bank credentials falls
under the umbrella of deceptive fishing
a general email is sent out to thousands
of users in this category hoping some of
them fall prey to this scam spear
fishing on the other hand is a bit
customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
drawback of deceptive fishing techniques
on the other hand a simple screenshot of
a Spotify playlist being shared on
social media indicates a probable point
of entry the hacker can send counterfeit
messages to the Target user while
implying the the source of such messages
being Spotify tricking them into sharing
private information since the hacker
already knows the target use of Spotify
the chances of victims taking the bait
increase substantially for more
important targets like CEOs and people
with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10 full which can be
called a case of wailing the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their fishing attack often to
steal industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price
apart from just emails farming focuses
on fake websites that resemble their
original counterparts as much as
possible the prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit web page which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cach poisoning but they
are rarely carried out due to time and
resource constraints now that we know
how fishing attacks work let's look at
ways to prevent ourselves from becoming
victims while the implications of a
fishing attack can be extreme protecting
yourself against these is relatively
straightforward Jane could have saved
herself from credit card fraud had she
checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that a redirected to a
secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or popup
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they seem it is also recommended to use
secure anti-fishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
emails from legitimate ones the best way
to prevent fishing is browsing the
internet with care and being on alert
for malicious attempts at all
times if you're an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from the
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply L postgraduate program in
cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice for more details you
can use the link mentioned in the
description box below these DS attacks
are getting more extreme with hackers
getting easy access to botet farms and
compromis devices as can be seen in the
graph three of the six strongest d do
attacks were launched in 2021 with the
most extreme attack occurring just last
year in 2020 lately cyber criminals have
been actively seeking out new services
and protocols for amplifying these DS
attacks active involvement with hacked
machines and botet allow further
penetration into the consumer space
allowing much more elaborate attack
campaigns apart from General users
multinational corporations have also had
their fair share of problems GitHub a
platform for software developers was the
target of a DS attack in 2018 widely
suspected to be conducted by Chinese
authorities this attack went on for
about 20 minutes after which the systems
were brought into a stable condition it
was the strongest DS attack to date at
the time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
combat such attacks even after years of
experimentation DS attacks are still at
large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space
hey everyone this is BB from Simply
learn and welcome to this video on what
is a DS attack let's learn more about
what is a Dos
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or dos is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered this can
be achieved by thating access to
virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions with within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a DS attack comes from
multiple systems generally these attacks
work by Drowning a system with requests
for data this could be sending a web
server so many requests to serve a page
that it crashes under the demand or it
could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center the bots in
the network attack a particular Target
thereby hiding the original perpetrator
of the DS campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how dos attack
work a DS attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
bot net of devices simply put a vast
network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
anytime to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the botn net the
devices in this networks are called Bots
or zombies in the second phase a
particular Target is selected for the
attack when the hacker finds the right
time to attack all the zombies in the
botnet network send these requests to
the Target thereby taking up all the
servers available bandwidth these can be
simple ping requests or complex attacks
like SN flooding and UDP flooding the
aim is to overwhelm them with more
traffic than the server or the network
can accommodate the goal is to render
the website or service
inoperable there's a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of DS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
targets vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of Dos
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks the size of volume
based attack is measured in bits per
second these attacks focus in clogging
all the available bandwidth for the
server thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balancers and firewalls which are meant
to protect the system against the dors
attacks these protocol attacks include
SN floods and Smurf DDOS among others
and the size is measured in packets per
second for example in an SSL handshake
server replies to the Hello message sent
by the hacker which will be the client
in this case but since the IP is poofed
and leads nowhere the server gets stuck
in an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application lay attacks
are conducted by flooding applications
with maliciously crafted requests the
size of application layer attacks is
measured in requests per second these
are relatively sophisticated attacks
that Target the application and
operating system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network banded up to to the point of
a system crash examples of such an
attack are HTTP flooding and bgp
hijacking a single device can request
data from a server using HTTP post or
get without any
issues however when the requisite botn
net is instructed to bombard the server
with thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a Dos attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them the first option is to gain a
competitive Advantage many dos attacks
are conducted by hacking communities
against rival groups some organizations
hire such communities to stagger their
Rivals resources at a network level to
gain an advantage in the playing field
since being a victim of a DS attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
signific ific an hit allowing the rivals
to cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launch
these Doos attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom the resources are
jammed and the only way to clear the way
is if the target company agrees to pay a
designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactivity
is detrimental to a company's reputation
in the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a
while DS attacks have also found use in
the political segment certain activists
tend to use dedos attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
Forum primarily political these attacks
also focus on online communities ethical
dilemas or even protest against
corporations let's take a look at a few
ways that companies and individual uals
can protect themselves against redos
attacks the company can employ load
balancers and firewalls to help protect
the data from such attacks load balances
reroute the traffic from one server to
another in a DS attack this reduces the
single point of failure and adds
resiliency to the server data a firewall
blocks unwanted traffic into a system
and manages the number of requests made
at a definite rate it checks for
multiple attacks from a single IP and
additional slowdowns to detect a Dos
attack in
action early detection of a Dos attack
goes a long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious DS traffic before it reaches
your server so that it doesn't throttle
and exhaust your bandwidth here's where
you will filter the traffic so that only
legitimate traffic reaches the server by
intelligent rout in you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by your cluster
resources the most important stage in DS
mitigation is where you will look for
patterns of Dos attacks and use those to
analyze and strengthen your mitigation
techniques for example blocking an IP
that's repeatedly found to be offending
is a first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft Azure who offer
high levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from dos criminals the cloud also has
greater bandwidth than most private
networks so it is likely to fail if
under the pressure of increased DS
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a Beat one can also increase the
amount of bandwidth available to a host
server being targeted since DS attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc let's start with our demo regarding
the effects of Dos attacks on a system
for our demo we have have a single
device that will attack a Target making
it a Dos attack of sorts once a bot net
is ready multiple devices can do the
same and eventually emulate a DS attack
to do so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parad security operating system
running for a Target machine we will be
running another VMR instance of a
standard Linux distribution known as
Linux light in a Target device we can
use wire shark to determine when the
attack begins and see the effects of the
attack
accordingly this is Linux light which is
a target machine and this is par
security which is used by the hacker
when trying to launch a DS attack this
is just one of the DOR that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal
we use the command if
config and here we can find the IP
address now remember we're launching
this attack in VMware now the both the
instances of parro security and Linux
light are being run on my local network
so the address that you can see here is
192.168 72.1 129 which is a private
address this IP cannot be accessed from
outside the network basically anyone who
is not connected to my Wi-Fi when
launching attacks with public servers or
public addresses it will have a public
IP address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool
called hping
3 hping 3 is an open- Source package
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol
call to check what are the effects of an
attack we will be using wire shark wire
shark is a network traffic analyzer you
can see whatever traffic that is passing
through the Linux light drro is being
displayed over here with the IP address
the source IP and the destination IP as
to where the request is being
transferred to once we have the Dos
attack launched you can see the results
coming over here from The Source IP
which will be par security Now to launch
the hping 3 command we need to give
pseudo access to the console which is
the root
access now we have the root axis for the
console the hping 3 command will have a
few arguments to go with it which are as
you can see on the
screen minus s and a
flood a hyphen V
hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is 1921 168
72129 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies SN packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection
The Hyphen flood aims to ignore the
replies that the server will send back
to the client in response to the SN
packet here the par security OS is the
client and Linux slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shock it is relatively clear and there
is no indication of a DS attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over
here we can see the request coming in
from this IP which is 192 168
72128 till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light
the requests keep on coming and we can
see the
HTTP flooding has started in flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a back
end now remember Linux light is a drro
and such Linux dros are served as
backend to many servers across the world
for example a few seconds have passed
from the attack now the system has
become completely IR responsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from par
security you can see whatever I pressed
nothing is responded even the wire shark
has stopped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux Destro
or where this Linux Destro is being used
as a backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a Dos attack as in a single
system is being used to penetrate a
Target server using a single request now
when a Dos attack multiple systems such
as multiple Pirro security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and
inoperable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for educational
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any need domains only test
this on servers and networks that you
have permission to test on cyber
security has become one of the most
rigid Industries in the last decade
while simultaneously being the most
challenged with every aspect of
corporate culture going online and
embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one Brute Force
attacks are simple and reliable there is
no prior knowledge needed about the
victim to start an attack most of the
systems falling prey to Brute Force
attacks are actually well
secured attackers let a computer do the
work that is trying different
combinations of usernames and passwords
until they find a one that works due to
this repeated trial and error format the
strength of password matters a great
deal although with enough time and
resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
begin with learning about Brute Force
attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of targ
targeted password until the current
password is discovered it can be used to
break into online accounts encrypted
documents or even Network peripheral
devices the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be timec
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data aisc are used and
at times downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative ative to Brute Force
attacks but the attacker already has a
list of usernames and passwords that
need to be tested against the target it
doesn't need to create any other
combinations on its own dictionary
attacks are much more reliable than
brute force in a real world context but
the usefulness depends entirely on the
strength of passwords being used by the
general
population there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in detail
in step one we have to settle on a tool
that we are going to use for brute
forcing there are some popular names on
the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like K Linux and parro
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific 8 digigit word containing only
letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to guess the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break into a
specific encrypted document a social
media account or even devices at home
that connect to the internet let's say
there is a Wi-Fi router the generated
passwords are then fed into the
connection one after the other it is a
long and arduous process but the work is
left to the computer other than someone
manually clicking and checking each of
these
passcodes any password that doesn't
unlock the router is discarded and The
Brute Force tool simply moves on to the
next one this keeps going on until we
find the right combination which unlocks
the
router sometimes reaching the success
stage takes days and weeks which makes
it cumbersome for people with low
computing power at their disposal
however the ability to crack any system
in the world purely due to bad password
habits is very appealing and the general
public tends to stick with simple and
easy to use
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how Brute Force Works let's see if
we can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next
week let's move on to the harmful
effects of getting a system compromised
due to Brute Force
attacks a hack lap laptop or mobile can
have social media accounts logged in
giving the hackers free access to the
victim's connections it has been
reported on multiple occasions where
compromised Facebook accounts are
sending malicious links and attachments
to people on their friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute fored A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plane format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other
things one once a system is hacked it
can also be used as a mail server that
distributes spam across lists of victims
since the Hacked machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of its standing buil
Force attacks thanks to the sheer number
of combinations they can produce the
longer the password the less likely it
is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
that if a single account or password is
compromised due to a breach or a hack
the rest of the accounts are isolated
from the
incident two Factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific 2fa
applications like Ai and agis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for for 2of
course are much more reliable and
secure captur are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of Brute Force
considerably
a definite rule that locks the account
being hacked for 30 minutes after a
specific number of attempts is a good
way to prevent Brute Force attempts many
websites lock account for 30 minutes
after three failed password attempts to
secure the account against any such
attack on an additional note some
websites also send an email instructing
the user that there have been three
insecure attempts to log into the
website let's look at a demonstration of
how Brute Force attacks work in a real
real world situation the world has gone
Wireless with Wi-Fi taking the re in
every household it's natural that the
security will always be up for debate to
further test the security index and
understand Brute Force attacks you will
attempt to break into the password of a
wifi router for that to happen you first
need to capture a handshake file which
is a connection file from the Wi-Fi
router to a connecting device like a
mobile or a laptop the operating system
used for this process is parot security
a Linux distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more to start our demo we're going to
use a tool called air gedon which is
made to hack into wireless network
specifically
at this point it's going to check for
all the necessary scripts that are
installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode for now the WL X1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select
to be able to capture data over the air
we're going to need to put it in monitor
mode as you can see above it's written
it is in manage mode right now so we're
going to select option two which is to
put the interface in monitor
mode and its name is now dou land zero
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is the handshake
tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for
targets and press
enter you have to let this run for about
60 seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this es ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example the station that you can see
56 26 this is supposed to be the MAC
address of the device that is connected
to a router this BSS ID is supposed to
be which wi-fi it is connected to for
example 5895 d8 is this one which is the
go24 router so we already know which
router has a device connected to it and
we can use our attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C it will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture handshake
it says we have a valid WPA WPA2 Network
Target selected and that the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do air replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we go we have
the WPA handshake
file
once the handshake file is captured can
actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a do cap file for the
path we can let's say we can keep it in
a
desktop okay we give the
path and the hand shap file is generated
we can already see see a Target over
here same go24 router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu
since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option
one now to run the Brute Force tool we
have two options either we can go with
the air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with airack plus crunch
which is a Brute Force attack against a
handshake file we can go with option
two it can already detect the capture
file that we have generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the go24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10 and
as a rough guess let's say we put the
maximum length as
20 the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if we already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
you go with only uppercase characters
and numeric
characters go with option
7 and it's going to start
decrypting so how aircrack is working
right here you can see this pass phrase
over here the first five or six digits
are a it starts working its way from the
end from the last character it keeps
trying every single combination you can
see the last the fourth character from
the right side the D it'll eventually
turn to E because it keeps checking up
every single character from the end this
will keep going on until all the single
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever P phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
is the way we can Brute Force into Wi-Fi
routers anywhere in the world cyber
attacks are frequently made headlines in
today's digital environment at any time
everyone who uses a computer could
become a victim of a Cyber attack there
are various sorts of cyber tanks ranging
from fishing to password attacks in this
video we'll look into one such attack
that is known as botet but before we
begin if you love watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon never to miss an update to
begin with let's take a look at some of
the famous botp
the first one is Mir botet which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a network of bots that on
command perform basic and medium level
denial of service attacks then we have
the zoos bot is specifically designed
for attacking a system for Bank related
information and data now let's see what
exactly a botnet
is botnet refers to a network of
hijacked interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware each of these infected devices
are known as Bots and a hij criminal
known as bot harder remotely controls
them the Bots are used to automate large
scale attacks including Data Theft
server failure malware
propagation and denial of service
attacks now that we know what exactly a
bot net is let's dive deeper into
learning how bot net works
during the preparation of a botnet
network the first step involves
preparing the botn net Army after that
the connection between the bot net Army
and the control server established in
the end the launching of the attack is
done by the bot Herer let's understand
through a
illustration firstly we have a bought
Herer that initiates the attack
according to the control server commands
the devices that are infected with the
malware programs and begins to attack
the infected system let's see some
details regarding the preparation of the
botnet
army the first step is known as the
prepping the bot net Army the first step
is creating a bot net is to infect as
many as connected devices as possible
this ensures that there are enough Bots
to carry out the attack this way it
creates Bots either by exploiting the
security gaps in the software or
websites or using fishing attacks they
are often deployed through Trojan
horses for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with a specific malware that
connects the device back to the control
bot server a bot Herer uses command
programming to drive the bot's
actions and the last step is known as
launching the attack once infected a bot
allows access to admin level operation
like Gathering and stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitoring user activities performing
denial of service attacks including
other cyber
crimes now let's take a look at the B
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server and communication
protocols like IRC when The Bard Herer
issues a command to the server it is
then relate to the clients to perform
malicious
actions then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the BS are topological interconnected
and acts as both CN C servers that is
the server and the client to the hackers
adopt this approach to avoid detection
and single point
failure
in the end we will see some points on
some counter measure against bot net
attacks the first step is to have
updated drivers and system updates after
that we should avoid clicking random
popups or links that we often see on the
internet and lastly having certified
antivirus anti- spyware softwares and
firewall installed into a system will
protect against malware attack the
internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a Time on the web hi everyone
and welcome to the simply La Channel
today we will discuss a topic that
secretly records our input data that is
known as key loggers but before we begin
if you like watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an
update to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example
this is June she works in a business
firm where she manages the company's
data
regularly this is Jacob from the
information Department who is here to
inform her about some of the security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
her system was facing with which
included slow reaction speed and unusual
internet
activity as Jacob heard about the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems a system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key logging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she asked him about some
of the details regarding
it for today's topic we learn what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
the system to begin with we learn what
exactly the key logging
programmers as the name suggests key
logger is a malicious program or a tool
that is designed to record key strokes
that are typed during data input and
record them into a lock file then the
same program secretly sends these lock
files to its origin where they can be
used for malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging program is let's take a look how
they enter into the system
searching for a suitable driver for a
system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different pop that we
often see on social sites or different
media sites can lead to the installation
of key logging program into our
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key logging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
a keyboard lags behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cases when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present on the net which can harm our
system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arouse is API based the most
common key loging case which uses apis
to keep a log of the type data and share
it to its origin for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the syn internal and log set
then we have form grabbing based key
loggers as the name suggests they are a
based key loggers that store the form
data that is if we often use web forms
or different kinds of forms to enter
different data they can be recorded into
the system by the program and send it to
its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
and send it to its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where they
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit them
when hackers receive information about
the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the key logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key Lo
loing program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now let's take a look whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
logging issue or
not in the case of hand devices
infection of key loggers are low in
comparison to the computer systems as
they use Onre screen keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different kindes of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with a key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that installed the particular
malicious program into the
system now to prevent our system from
getting infected by the key locking
program let's take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering of
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good habit and lastly using virtual
keyboard to input our sensitive data
which may include Bank details login
details or different passwords related
to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the important libraries
that are required into the
system which is
this library now we'll run
it the system says the library is
already installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly modules are required from the
particular
library from this Library we'll
import the keyboard module which will
help us to record the data that we TP
type on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of code that will allow us to save
the data that is recorded by the program
into a text file that will be named as
key log text file along with the date
and time stamp let's take a
look now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given
as key log
do txt
file and also so the part where the
format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given
as the format would be the message and
the time stamp which would be given
as along with the time
stamp as percentage and ending it with
the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design two of the functions that will be
used into the program that will be
termed as while press function and while
release function let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed
is
pred
and this would go for the format that we
designed in the above
line
and
logging the Press
key
info or string file to be
recorded into the lock file
now now we'll design a function that is
while
release that will come into play
when
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from
running and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to to Loop these functions
that is while press and while release to
continue its
cycle that will be going for while press
and
on release will contain while
release
function
as listen
now and now this part would join the
different threads and store them into
the log file now that we have completed
the code for the program let's run
it
we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
notepad and on the notpad we'll
write hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the the main page
on Jupiter notebook and refresh the page
go to the
bottom over here we see the key log text
that is the text file that we created
let's open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we started with Note then
this is the hello world part that we
created just
now which shows that the program we
created created is working properly now
that we have reached the end of the
module let's take a look at the summary
firstly we learned what exactly key
loggers are then we understood what
different modes are present how the
system get infected with the key logging
problem then we learned how to detect
the problem into our system then we
learned what different types of key
loggers are present on the net we also
understood how hackers use the recorded
data from the program
and we also learn whether mobile devices
get infected with the key logging
problem or not and lastly we understood
what different points can be taken to
prevent the entering of the key logging
problem into the system before we learn
about the Pegasus platform let us
understand what spyware is and it's
working spyware is a category of malware
that can gather information regarding a
user or a device straight from the host
machine it is mostly spread by malicious
links via email or chat applications
when a link with the malware is received
clicking on this link will activate the
spyware which allows the hacker to spy
on all our user information with some
spy systems even clicking on the link
isn't necessary to trigger the malicious
payload this can ultimately cause
security complications and further loss
of privacy one such spy system that is
making the rounds in the tech industry
today is Pegasus the Pegasus is a
spyware system developed by an Israeli
company known as the NSO group it runs
are mainly mobile devices spanning
across the major operating systems like
the Apple's IOS on iPhone and the
standard Android versions this is not a
newly developed platform since Pegasus
has existed since as early as 2016 a
highly intricate spy program that can
track user location read text messages
scan through mobile files access device
camera and microphone to record voice
and video Pegasus has all the tools
necessary to enforce surveillance for
any client that wish to buy its services
initially the NSO group had designed the
software to be used against terrorist
factions of the world with more and more
encrypted communication channels coming
to the Forefront Pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
National Security unfortunately the
people who bought the software had
complete control over who how and up to
what level they can put surveillance
limits on eventually the primary clients
became Sovereign Nations spying on
public information that is supposed to
stay private became really easy with
this service multiple devices can be
affect With the same spyware system to
create a network information this
network keeps feeding data to the host
to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person's inbox they look like
generic emails which are supposed to be
safe the Pegasus spyware targets such
occurrences bypassing malicious messages
and links which install the necessary
Spy software on the user's mobile device
be it Android or an iPhone this isn't
unique to the email ecosystem since it's
equally likely to be t targeted by SMS
text WhatsApp Instagram or even the most
secure messaging apps like signal and
threa once the malicious links are
clicked a spyware package is downloaded
and installed on the device after the
spyware is successfully installed the
perpetrator who sent the payload to the
victim can monitor everything the user
does Pegasus can collect private emails
passwords images videos and every other
piece of information that passes to the
device Network all this data is is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex py software like Pegasus
can access the root files on our mobiles
these root files hold information that
is crucial to the working of the Android
and iOS operating systems leaking such
private information is a massive blow to
the security and the privacy of an
individual the information that may seem
trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible due to the zero
day vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these exploits are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action
feature usually in spam emails the
malicious code is activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp Gmail
or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being a affected by spyware as a victim
is detection unlike Crypt Miners and
Trojans spying Services usually do not
demand many system resources which makes
them tough to detect after they have
been activated since many devices slow
down after a couple of years any kind of
Performance Set due to such spyware is
often attributed to poor software
longetivity by the users they do not
check meticulously for any other causes
that is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if we are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall pre to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keeping the apps and phones updated
or D all of the above let us know your
answers in the comment section below and
we will rev the correct answer next week
but what about the unaffected devices
the vulnerable ones while we cannot be
certain of our security there are a few
things we can do to boost our device be
it against Pegasus or the next big spyer
on the market let's say we are safe now
and we have the time to take the
necessary steps to prevent a spare
attack what are the things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploits Target
are often dis covered by developers from
Google and apple which send the security
patches quickly this can be done for
individual apps as well so keeping them
updated is of utmost importance while
the most secure devices have fallen prey
to Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spyware platform altogether
another big factor is the spread of
malware is the trend of sideloading
Android applications using do APK files
downloading such apps from a third party
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spyware invasions on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into our
device we should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains spy is a controversial segment
in governance while the ramifications
are pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false ve of democracy
altogether even if our daily life is
rather simplistic we must understand
that privacy is not about what we have
to hide instead it portrays the things
we have to protect it stands for
everything we have to share with the
outside world both rhetorically and
literally hey everyone
today we look at the hack which took the
World by storm and affected multiple
governments and corporations the solar
winds attack the global statistics
indicate that upward of 18,000 customers
have been affected potentially needing
billions to recover the losses incurred
before we have a look at this hack Make
sure to subscribe to our Channel and hit
the notification Bell to never miss an
update from Simply learn the date is
December 8th 2020 firei a global leader
in company specializing in cyber
security
released a blog post that caught the
attention of the entire it Community a
software known as Orion which was
developed by solar wison corporator had
become a victim of a remote access
Trojan or a rat the breach was estimated
to be running since the spring of 2020
and went virtually unnoticed for months
the reveal sent the developers of the
Orion software into a frenzy as they
quickly released a couple of hot fixes
for the platform in order to mitigate
this threat and prevent further damage
but how did this come to existence we
first need to understand the platform
which was responsible for this preach
soloin a software company based in Texas
United States had developed a management
platform known as Orion cering to
corporations and governments worldwide
Orion was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization Network infrastructure that
bought the platform solar winds claims
they have more than 300,000 clients
including US government agencies and
several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferably services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it in this
case the Orion platform was the primary
target the culprit however was software
updates the update server for solar
Orion had a malicious version attached
with malware or a Trojan to be precise
this was made possible since the code
repository that handled the software
updates was breached once the update
server repository was compromised the
source code of the applications became
open to modification and malicious code
found its way onto the software the
remote access troen was attached to a
potential update nicknamed the Sunburst
update this update gave hackers pack
door access to any client that uses the
correct version on its release many
clients believe the update to be
legitimate since it came from the right
source and they had no reason to believe
otherwise American government agencies
were supposedly hit the hardest as the
list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issues
quick updates to fix this
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believed
that this was an act of crossborder
corporate Espionage conducted by state
sponsored hackers either from Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malware was responsible for
the solar wind hack was it one a virus a
remote access trojen a spyware or a worm
let us know your answers in the comment
section right away and we will reveal
the correct answer in a week coming to
possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encouraged since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also a strict
no as is installing applications from
unverified sources the solar wind hack
is estimated to cost the parent company
nearly $18 million as reparations making
it one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history as recently as of
July 2021 the hackers access some us
attorney's Microsoft 365 email accounts
as part of the attack criminal
organizations like the FB I and CIA are
determined to figure out the culprits
responsible for this debacle however the
intricacy and the full extent of the
breach makes it a way more complicated
job than it looks on paper the day is
26th February
2022 the world is hit with breaking news
that Russian State tv channels have been
hacked by Anonymous a activist
Collective and movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple Cyber Wars
in the past decade this was in response
to the Russian aggression on Ukrainian
territory in the hopes of annexation
Anonymous hacked the Russian State TV
networks to combat propaganda in Russia
and highlight the damage to life Meed
out by the Kremlin in Ukraine they also
hacked 120,000 Russian troops personal
information and the Russian Central Bank
stealing 35,000 files this served as a
clear indicator of how cyber War can
change the momentum in battle something
which people had never seen so closely
so what is cyber War a digital assault
or series of strikes or hacks against a
country is sometimes referred to as a
cyber War it has the ability to cause
havoc on government and civilian
infrastructure as well as disrupt
essential systems causing State harm and
even death in this day an age the
internet plays a bigger role than just
watching videos and learning content
it's where you have your personal data
and carry Financial transactions so
rather than resorting to physical
violence cyber War has become the new
means to cause Havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet in most
circumstances cyber warfare involves a
nation state attacking another in
certain cases the assaults are carried
out by terrorist organizations or
non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in June 2021 Chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
Verizon to secure remote access to their
networks stuck net was a computer warm
designed to attack Iran's nuclear
facilities but evolved and expanded to
many other industrial and energy
producing sites in
2010 since the definition of cyber war
is so vague applying rules and sanctions
based on digital assault is even tougher
making the field of cyber warfare a
lawless land not bound by any rules or
policies there are multiple ways in
which these attacks can be carried out a
major category of Cyber attack is
espionage Espionage entails monitoring
other countries to steal critical
Secrets this might include compromising
vulnerable computer systems with botn
Nets or spear fishing attempts before
extracting sensitive data in cyber
warfare the next weapon in cyber war is
sabotage government agencies must
identify sensitive data and its dangers
if it is exploited Insider threats such
as disgruntled or irresponsible
Personnel or government staff with ties
to the attacking country can be used by
hostile countries or terrorist to steal
or destroy information by overwhelming a
website with bogus requests and forc ing
it to handle them denial of service
attacks prohibit real users from
accessing it attacking parties may use
this form of assault to disrupt key
operations and systems and prevent
citizens military and security officials
and research organizations from
accessing sensitive websites but what
benefits does Cyber War offer in
contrast to traditional physical Warfare
the most important Advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
Global without having to travel
thousands thousand of Miles as long as
the attacker and Target are connected to
the internet organizing and launching
Cyber Wars is relatively less tedious
Than Physical Warfare people living in
or battling for a country are subjected
to propaganda attacks in an attempt to
manipulate their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
in today's modern world starting from
communication channels to Secure Storage
servers crippling a country's footprint
and control on the Internet is very
damaging but what are some of the ways
we as Citizens protect ourselves in the
case of a cyber war in the unfortunate
event that your country is involved in
Warfare be sure to fact check every
piece of information and follow only
trusted sources in that frame of time
even conversations online should be
limited to a need to know basis
considering propaganda campaigns have
the power to influence the tide of War
drastically it is highly crucial to
follow basic security guidelines to
secure our devices like regularly
updating our op operating systems
occasionally running full system
antivirus scans Etc if your country or
organization is being attacked having
devices segregated in a network goes a
long way in bolstering
security try to avoid sharing a lot of
personal data online in this era of
Instagram and Facebook divulging private
information can be detrimental to
keeping a secure firewall for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate
defenses if you're an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from the
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply lar postgraduate program in
cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice for more details you
can use the link mentioned in the
description box below we bring you the
top 10 computer hacks of all time but
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting Tech videos every
day let's see what we have at number 10
from April 27 2007 Estonia the European
country faced a series of cyber attacks
that lasted for weeks this happened when
the Estonian government decided to move
the bronze soldier from Talent Center to
a less prominent military cemetery
located on the city's
outskirts precental levels of internet
traffic took down Estonian Banks online
services media Outlets broadcasters and
government bodies botnet sent massive
waves of spam and vast amounts of
automated Online requests according to
researchers the public fa dos attacks
there were conflicts to edit the English
language version of the Bron soldiers
Wikipedia page as well although there is
no confirmation Russia is believed to be
behind these cyber attacks that largely
crippled the Estonian Society let's now
move on to the next attack on December
23rd 2015 several parts of Ukraine
witnessed a par outage and this was not
a typical blackout it was indeed the
result of a Cyber attack Information
Systems of three energy distribution
companies in Ukraine were compromised it
is the first known Victorious Cyber
attack on a par grid it is said that
here hackers sent out fishing emails to
the par companies 30 substations were
Switched Off and about 230,000 people
were left in the dark for about 1 to six
SS us investigators believed that Russia
based hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a Cyber attack caused a
21-day shutdown of NASA computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15-year-old
Jonathan James he first penetrated US
Department of Defense division's
computers and installed a back door on
its servers this allowed him to
intercept more than a thousand
government emails including the ones
containing usernames and passwords this
helped James steal a piece of NASA
software and crack the NASA computers
that support the International Space
Station which caused a space exploration
agency's
$41,000 as systems were shut down for 3
weeks he was the first person to carry
out a computer hack against the American
space agency let's now move on to the
next attack in l November 2014 there was
a leak of confidential data from the
film studio of son pictures information
about son pictures employees their
emails copies of the then unreleased
Sony films future propositions and other
crucial data were leaked this Cyber
attack was carried out by a hacker group
named Guardians Of Peace so what did the
hackers want well they demanded that
Sony withdraw its then upcoming movie
the interview this movie was a comedy
story line to assassinate the North
Korean leader Kim jnun Sony then decided
to cancel the film's theatrical release
due to the threats at Cinema screening
the movie it is indeed hard to trace the
roots of a Cyber attack in this case
after evaluation the US intelligence
officials arrived with the theory that
the attack was in a way related to the
government of North Korea however North
Korea had denied the same moving on to
our number six in December 2006 TJX the
US retailer company identified that 45.6
million debit and credit card details
were stor
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data as a result banks
in the affected regions had to reissue
and block thousands of payment cards a
group of hackers did this Albert
Gonzalez being The Mastermind the group
was from Miami the place where the TJX
Heist was believed to have originated
reports said that the TJX data breach
occurred because of of weak web
encryption at two of its Marshall stores
in Miami next moving on to our top five
let us see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuck net this
Mal's motive was unlike any other usual
cyber attacks it aimed at destructing
the equipment the computers controlled
stuck net came with the deadly purpose
of damaging Iran's nuclear
infrastructure it infected more than
200,000 Compu mters including 14
Industrial sites and a uranium
enrichment plant in Iran stuck net
initially spread via Microsoft Windows
and targeted seens industrial Control
Systems although it was discovered only
in 2010 It is believed to have been
silently sabotaging Iran's nuclear
facilities it was one of the first
discovered malware that was capable of
hampering hardware systems it largely
damaged the centrifuges of the Iranian
reactors this is believed to be a cyber
weapon created by the US and the Israeli
intelligence although there is no
documented evidence or acceptance by
either of the countries for the same
moving on to number four in the year
2014 Home Depot was the victim of one of
the deadliest cyber attacks 56 million
payment cards were compromised along
with 53 million customer email addresses
stolen this security breach happened
from April to September 2014 criminals
were believed to have used a third
partyy wendor username as password to
enter the perimeter of Home Depot's
Network the attackers were then able to
deploy custombuilt malware on its self
checkout systems in the US and Canada
moving on to our top three as you might
be aware the PlayStation gaming system
is one of Sony's most popular products
unfortunately in April 2011 Sony
Executives witnessed abnormal activity
on the PlayStation Network this resulted
in the compromise of approximately 77
million PlayStation users accounts and
prevented users of PlayStation 3 and
PlayStation Portable consoles from
accessing the service this forced Sony
to turn off the PlayStation Network on
April 20th on May 4th Sony confirmed
that personally identifiable information
from each of the 77 million accounts had
been exposed the outage lasted for 23
days Sony released almost daily
announcements concerning the system
outage in the end Sony is believed to
have invested approximately 1 $70
million to improve the network security
to investigate the attack and to cover
the expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in May
2017 one of the most dangerous cyber
attacks took place it was known as the
wry ransomware attack caused by the wry
crypto worm the victims were the users
that used the unsupported version of
Microsoft Windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update this
did not take place through fishing like
other attacks but through an exposed
vulnerable SMB Port the attack
originated in Asia and then eventually
spread across the globe in a day more
than 200,000 computers were infected
across 150
countries the W cry crypto worm locked
the users out of the targeted systems
and encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of $300 to $600 which
had to be paid via Bitcoin in exchange
for their dat
this attack took a toll on both private
and government organizations it resulted
in Damages from hundreds of millions to
billions of dollars in a matter of few
days the emergency patches released by
Microsoft halted the attack also the
discovery of a kill switch prevented the
infected computers from spreading the
crypto worm Security Experts and a few
countries believed that North Korea was
behind this attack and finally let's see
what we have at number one more than two
decades ago in March 1999 the Melissa
virus a mass mailing macro virus was
released it targeted Microsoft Word and
Outlook based systems and created
considerable Network traffic Melissa
virus infected computers via emails the
email would look like an important
message well yes it was fake if the
recipient opens the attachments in the
mail and downloads the document and then
opens it with Microsoft Word a virus was
released on their
computers this would then massmail
itself to the first 50 people in the
victim's contact list and then disable
multiple Safeguard features on Microsoft
Word and Microsoft Outlook this began
spreading like a wildfire across the
internet David L Smith released the
virus the virus cost nearly 80 million
worth of Damages it did not steal data
or money however it cost a Havoc almost
1 million email accounts were disrupted
worldwide agencies were overloaded and
some had to be shut down entirely and
internet traffic in some locations was
slowed down security was traditionally
considered an afterthought in software
development it is becoming an
increasingly important concern for all
aspects of app development from design
to deployment and Beyond the number of
programs produced distributed deployed
and patched across Network continually
increases as a result application
security features must deal with a wide
range of risks let's take an example a
malicious script may be mirrored on the
victim's web browser or kept in a
database and run whenever the user
contacts the proper function depending
on the kind of attack in question here
this allows malicious code to be entered
in the case of an output the major cause
of this attack is faulty user input
validation which allows malicious input
to enter the final output an evil user
can enter a script that will be injected
into the website code the browser will
then be unable to determine whether the
process code is harmful as a result of a
malicious script is performed on the
victim's browser or a bogus form is
shown to the users are you aware of
which attack this is if not do stay till
the end to find the correct answer are
you aware of which attack this is if not
please stay till the end of the video to
know the correct answer hey everyone
welcome to today's video on application
security before we move forward
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
us let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today we start by learning about
application security and its different
types we learn about the most common
vulnerabilities in abset followed by the
importance of application Security in
today's cyber security
space next we cover some attacks against
application layer security and end the
video with some protection techniques to
enforce application security parameters
so let's start by learning about
application security from a Grassroots
perspective application security which
is often known as app protects
application software from external
security threats by utilizing security
software Hardware methodologies best
practices and different processes
organizations require application
security technologies that Safeguard all
of their programs from internal to
popular external apps on consumer mobile
phones these Solutions must address the
whole development cycle and provide
testing after an application has been
deployed to detect possible issues
application security mechanism must be
capable of testing web page for possible
and exploitable vulnerabilities
analyzing code and assisting in the
administration of development and Safety
Management processes the testing
Solutions must also be simple and easy
to install for system administrators
worldwide consumers utilize hundreds of
applications daily to access
theoretically important and favored
services such as e-commerce banking
music Etc to be productive these
professionals use a variety of software
Solutions as well r in from online word
Checkers to tablet based creative tools
among other things backend software of
course exists to automate essential
operations and processes and decreases
human labor but to make matters worse
the quantity and complexity of these
apps and the backend code is increasing
the software security problem 10 years
ago was about securing desktop apps and
static web pages that were natively
harmless and easy to scale through and
defend because of Outsource development
the number of Legacy programs and
in-house development that uses
third-party open- source and
commercialized offthe shelf software
modules the software supply chain has
become considerably more
convoluted now that we understand
application Security on a general level
let us go through some of the different
categories or the types of application
security the three major types to be
covered in this section web application
security API security and Cloud native
application security
a web application is a program available
through the internet and it operates on
a web server the client is accessed
using a web browser the applications by
definition must allow connections from
clients across unsecured Network this
exposes them to a variety of risks many
online apps are mission critical and
include sensitive customer data making
them an attractive Target for attackers
and a top concern for any cyber security
program or framework the Adent of https
which which offers an encrypted channel
of communication Gs versus man in the
middle attacks or mitm attacks has
addressed several online application
weaknesses many weaknesses though still
persist many security providers have
created Solutions specifically geared to
safeguard online applications in
response to the rising challenge of web
application security a web application
firewall is an example of a security
technology meant to identify and prevent
application layer sols in the case of
web application s when it comes to apis
apis that have security flaws are the
root of many major data breaches they
have the potential to reveal sensitive
data and disrupt vital corporate
processes API security flaws include
insufficient authentication unintended
data disclosure and a failure to apply
rate restriction which allows API abuse
the requirement for API security like
the necessity for web application
security has led to the creation of
sophisticated equipment that can
discover API vulnerabilities and protect
apis in production level the third type
is cloud native application security
infrastructure and environments are
often built up automatically in Cloud
native apps depending on declarative
configuration which is known as
infrastructure as code or IAC developers
are tasked with developing declarative
settings and application code both of
which should be secure because
practically everything is defined during
the development stage shifting left is
even more more crucial in Cloud native
setups traditional testing techniques
can help Cloud native apps but they are
insufficient dedicated Cloud native
Security Solutions are mandatory at this
point of time which are capable of
instrumenting vessels container clusters
and serverless operations reporting on
security concerns and providing
developers with a quick feedback loop
now that you have covered the different
types of application security let us go
through some of the most common
vulnerabilities that these Frameworks
face on a daily basis
first is cryptographic failure when data
is not adequately safeguarded in transit
and at rest cryptographic failures which
are forly known as sensitive data
exposures occur it has the potential to
reveal credentials health information
credit card details and personal
information as well depending on the
type of data being protected in that
particular case injection attacks C
actors can use injection vulnerabilities
to convey malicious information to a web
application interpreter
it has the potential to assemble and
execute this data on the server SQL
injection is a popular type of injection
which I've already covered in an
introduction for this
video another major vulnerability are
outdated components vulnerable and out
update components Encompass any
vulnerability caused by obsolete or
unmaintained software it can happen if
you construct or even use an application
without first learning about its core
components and
versions authentication failures
identification and authentication
failure which are previously known as
broken authentication enpass any
security issue involving user identities
identity attacks and exploitation may be
avoided by implementing secure session
Administration authentication and
validation for all identities in the
organization in the next section let us
cover some of the protection mechanisms
employed by cyber security firms and
thirdparty automated software to prevent
the application layer from being
bombarded with SQL injections and other
attacks the first is a web application
firewall or
WF a web application firewall monitors
and filters HTTP traffic between a web
application and the worldwide web web
application firewall architecture does
not address all risks but it may be used
in conjunction with other defense
mechanisms it can be us to the portfolio
of Security Solutions to provide a
comprehensive defense against diverse
back roads it is a protocol layer 7
protection in the open systems
interconnection or the OSI model
Paradigm that helps defend online
application against attacks such as
cross-site scripting cross-site fraud
esip injection and file
inclusion unlike a proxy server which
conceals the identity of client
computers by an intermediary AWA
functions as a reverse proxy shielding
the server from exposure it acts as a
barrier in front of a web application
protecting it from the internet the
clients must pass through the web
application firewall before they can
access the
application the second is threat
assessment a list of sensitive assets to
safeguard will assist you in
understanding the threat to your firm
and how to minimize them considering how
a hacker can infiltrate an application
if existing security protections are in
place and whether additional tools or
defense capabilities are required it's
also crucial to keep your security
expectations in check nothing is
impenetrable even at the most stringent
security measures it would be best if
you were realistic about what you
believe your team can handle in the long
run when pushed to aggressively safety
regulations and procedures might be
disregarded remember that safety is a
lengthy and time-taking project that
requires the collaboration of other
employees and sometimes even your
customers the next topic is privilege
management limiting privileges is vital
especially for Mission critical and
sensitive systems the least PR preg
principle states that access to programs
and data should be limited to those who
require them when they require them for
two reasons the least privileged
principle is absolutely
critical the first is that hackers May
compromise less privileged accounts and
ensuring they do not acquire access to
highly sensitive systems is
critical the second is that internal
dangers are equally harmful as external
adversaries if insiders go bad it's
critical to ensure they never have more
power than they need minimizing the harm
that they may be able to cause to the
organization network security is a set
of technologies that protects the
usability and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network it
architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it effective
network security strategies employ
multiple lines of defense that are
scalable and automated each defensive
layer here enforces a set of security
policies which are determined by the
administrator beforehand this aims at
securing the confidentiality and
accessibility of the data and the
network the every company or
organization that handles a large amount
of data has a degree of solutions
against many cyber threats the most
basic example of network security is
password protection it has the network
the user chooses the recently network
security has become the central topic of
cyber security with many organizations
involving applications from people with
skills in this area it is crucial for
both personal and professional networks
most houses with highspeed internet have
one or more wireless routers which can
be vulnerable to attacks if they're not
adequately
secured data loss theft and sabotage
risk may be decreased with the usage of
a strong network security system the
workstations are protected from
hazardous F thanks to network security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network
by dividing information into various
sections encrypting these portions and
transferring them over separate Pathways
network security infrastructure offers
multiple levels of protection to th man
in the midle attacks preventing
situations like eavesdropping among
other harmful attacks it is becoming
increasingly difficult in today's
hyperconnected environment as more
corporate applications migrate to both
public and private clocks additionally
modern applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team Network traffic
and infrastructure must be protected in
these cases since assaults on businesses
are increasing every single day we now
understood the basics of network
security but we need to understand how
network security works in the next
section in slightly more detail network
security revolves around two processes
authentication and
authorization the first process which is
authentication is similar to access
cards which ensure that only those have
the right to enter a building in other
words authentication checks and verifies
that it is indeed the user belonging to
the network is trying to access or enter
it thereby preventing unauthorized
intrusions next comes
authorization this process decides the
level of access provided to the recently
authenticated
user for example Network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working within it prob need access
to only certain areas within the network
based on the network user role the
process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization today's Network
architecture is complex and faces a
threat environment that is always
changing and attackers that are always
trying to find and exploit
vulnerabilities these vulnerabilities
can exist in many areas including
devices data applications users and
locations for this reason many Network
Security Management tools and
applications are in use today that
address individual
threats when it's just a few minutes of
downtime can cause widespread disruption
and massive damage to an organization's
bottom line and reputation it is
essential that these protection measures
are in place
beforehand now that you know a little
about network security and its working
let's cover to the different types of
network
security the fundamental tenant of
network security is the layering of
protection for massive networks and
store data that ensure the acceptance of
rules and regulations as a whole there
are three types the first of which is
physical security the next being
Technical and the third being
administrative let's look into physical
security first this is the most basic
level that includes protecting data and
network to unauthorized Personnel from
acquiring control over the
confidentiality of the network this
include external peripherals and routers
that might be used for cable connections
the same can can be achieved by using
devices like biometric systems physical
security is critical especially for
small businesses that do not have many
resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large
firms when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions this kind fulfills two
functions one is defense against
unauthorized users the other is a
defense against malevolent actions
the last category is Administrative this
level of network security protects user
Behavior like how the permission has
been granted and how the authorization
process takes place this also ensures
the level of sophistication the network
might need to protect it through all the
attacks this level also suggest
necessary amendments that have to be
done to the
infrastructure I think that's all the
basics that we need to cover on network
security in which our next topic we're
going to go through two mediums of
network security which are the transport
layer and the application
layer so transport layer is a way to
secure information as it is carried over
the Internet with users browsing
websites emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with a
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties to the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates the token it is used
for all Communications the connection
employs lighter symmetric cryptography
to save bandwidth and processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface po app layer security can lead
to Performance and stability issues data
theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denal
of service attacks or DDOS attacks HTTP
floods injections cross-site scripting
Etc most organizations have an arsenal
of application layer security
protections to combat these and more
such as web application firewalls secure
web Gateway Services Etc now that we
have the theory behind network security
has been covered in detail let us go
through some of the tools that can be
used to enforce these network security
policies the first tool to be covered in
the section is a firework a fire W is a
type of network security device that
keeps track of incoming and outgoing
Network traffic and it decides which
traffic to allow or deny in accordance
to a set of security rules for more than
25 years firewalls have served as
Network Security's first line of defense
they provide a barrier between
trustworthy internal protected and
regulated networks from Shady external
networks like the internet at some
point the next tool which can be used to
bolster network security is a virtual
private Network networ or VPN for short
it's an encrypted connection between a
device and a network via the Internet
the encrypted connection AIDS the secure
transmission of sensitive data it makes
it impossible for unauthorized parties
to e drop on the traffic and enables
remote work for the user the usage of
VPN technology is common in both
corporate and personal networks next we
cover the importance of intrusion
prision systems in network security or
IPS Frameworks an intrusion prevention
system is a network security tool that
continually scans the network for
harmful activity and responds to it when
it does occur by reporting blocking or
discarding it it can be either Hardware
or software it's more sophisticated that
an intuition detection system or an IDs
framework which can just warn an
administrator and merely identify
harmful activities while in the case of
an IPS it actually takes against that
activity the next tool in this section
and the final one are going to be
behavioral Analytics
Behavior analytics focus more on the
statistics that are being carried over
and stored through months and years of
usage on some kind of similar pattern is
noted but the it administrator can
detect some kind of attack the similar
attacks can be stopped and the security
can be further enhanced and now that we
have covered all that we need to know
about network security the necessary
tools it's different types Etc let's go
to the benefits of network security as a
whole the first which is protection
against external threats the objective
for cyber assaults can be as varied as
the Defenders themselves although
they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and covert the attacks are
getting a strong cyber security posture
that considers routine software updates
May assist firms in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry points
the next benefit is protection against
internal threats the human aspect
continues to be the cyber security
systems weakest link Insider risk can
originate from current or former workers
third party vendors or even trusted
partners and they can be unintentional
careless or downright even aside from
that the rapid expansion of remote work
and the personal devices used for
business purposes while even iot devices
in remote locations can make it easier
for these kind of threats to go
undetected until it's too late however
by proactively monitoring networks and
managing access these dangers may be
identified and dealt with before they
become expensive
disasters the third benefit is increased
productivity it nearly impossible for
employees to function when networks and
personal devices are slow to crawl by
viruses and other cyber attacks during
the operation of website and for the
company to run you may significantly
minimize violations and the amount of
downtime required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls
virus scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email fishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training another benefit is brand trust
and
reputation customer retention is one of
the most crucial elements in business
development customers today place a
premium on maintaining brand loyalty
through a strong cyber security stance
since this is the fastest way to get
other businesses back get referrals and
sell more tickets overall additionally
it helps manufacturers get on the vendor
list with bigger companies as a part of
the supply chain which is only as strong
as its weakest link this opens
possibilities of potential future
endeavors and development with the rise
in censorship and general fear over
privacy loss consumer security is at an
all-time high risk technology has made
our life so much easier while putting up
a decent Target on a personal
information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
Safeguard our data and be up to date
with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on cryptography but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography meet an Anne wanted to look
for a decent discount on the latest
iPhone she started searching on the
internet and found a rather Shady
website that offered a 50% discount on
the first purchase once Anne submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after devastated and
quickly realized she had failed to
notice that the website was a http web
page instead of an https one the payment
information submitted was not encrypted
and it was visible to anyone keeping an
i including the website owner and
hackers had she used a reputed website
which has encrypted transactions and
employees cryptography our iPhone
Enthusiast could have avoided this
particular incident this is why it's
never recommended to visit unnown
websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today we take a
look into what cryptography is and how
it works we learn where cryptography is
being used in our daily lives and how we
are benefiting from it then we will
understand the different types of
cryptography and their respective users
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action let's Now
understand what crypto rography
is cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties encryption is a primary route
for employing cryptography by adding
certain algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography for example when simply
learn is jumbled up or changed in any
format not many people can guess the
original word by looking at the
encrypted text the only ones who can are
the people who know how to decrypt the
coded word thereby reversing the process
of
encryption any data pre- encryption is
called plain text or clear text to
encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tools
these algorithms are called ciphers they
are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
cipher text and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content wonder what else we would lose
if not for
cryptography any website where you have
an account can read your passwords
important emails can be intercepted and
their contents can be read without
encryption during the transit more than
65 billion messages are sent on WhatsApp
every day all of which are secured
thanks to endtoend
encryption there is a huge Market
opening up for cryptocurrency which is
possible due to blockchain technology
that uses encryption algorithms and
hashing functions to ensure that the
data is secure if this is of particular
interest to you you can watch our video
on blockchain the link of which will be
in the description of course there is no
single solution to a problem as diverse
as explained there are three variants of
how cryptography works and is in
practice they are symmetric encryption
asymmetric
encryption and hashing
let's find out how much we have
understood until now do you remember the
difference between a cipher and Cipher
text leave your ANS is in the comments
and before we proceed if you find this
video interesting make sure to give it a
thumbs up before moving ahead let's look
at symmetric encryption
first symmetric encryption uses a single
key for both the encryption and
decryption of data it is comparatively
less secure than asymmetric encryption
but much faster it is a compromise that
has to be embraced in order to deliver
data as fast as possible without living
information completely vulnerable this
type of encryption is used when data
rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times Caesar Cipher Enigma
machine are both symmetric encryption
examples that we we will look into
further for example if Alice wants to
send a message to Bob she can apply a
substitution shifer or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message symmetric
encryption uses one of the two types of
ciphers stream ciphers and block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
to convert it into Cipher text stream
ciphers convert the plain text into
Cipher text one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks in today's world the most
widely used symmetric encryption
algorithm is AES 256 that stands for
advanced encryption standard which has a
key size of 256bit with 128bit and 196
bit key sizes also being available other
primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the dees the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
Blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of AES AES chops UPS the
data into blocks and performs 10 plus
rounds of obscuring and substituting the
message to make it
unreadable asymmetric encryption on the
other hand has a double whammy at its
disposal there are two different keys at
play here a public key and a private key
the public key is used to encrypt
increation pre-transit and a private key
is used to decrypt the information post
Transit if Alice wants to communicate
with Bob using a symmetric encryption
she encrypts the message using Bob's
public key after receiving the message
Bob uses his own private key to decrypt
the data this way nobody can intercept
the message in between transmissions and
there is no need for any secure key
exchange for this to work since the
encryption is done with the public key
and the decryption is done with a
private key that no one except Bob has
access to both the keys are necessary to
read the full
message there is also a reverse scenario
where we can use a private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message this
mechanism also proves that the sender is
authenticated and there is no problem
with the origin of the
information RSA encryption is the most
widely used asymmetric encryption
standard it is named after its Founders
revest Shamir and Edelman and it uses
block ciphers that separate the data
into blocks and obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than AES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification VPN
emails and chat
applications with so much hanging on the
key secrecy the must be a way to
transmit the keys without others reading
our private data many systems use a
combination of symmetric encryption and
asymmetric encryption to bolster
security and match speed at the same
time since asymmetric encryption takes
longer to decrypt large amounts of data
the full information is encrypted using
a single key that is symmetric
encryption that single key is then
transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the Diffy helpman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into the third
variant of cryptography is termed as
hashing hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of data beyond
recognition it gives an output of fixed
size which is known as the hash value of
the original data or just hash in
general the calculations that do the job
of messing up the data collection form
the hash function they are generally not
reversible without resilient Brute Force
mechanisms and are very helpful when
storing data on website servers that
need not be stored in Blaine text for
example many websites store your account
passwords in a hashed format so that not
even the administrator can read your
credentials when a user tries to log in
they can compare the entered password's
hash value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
authentication since the function will
always return the same value for the
same
input cryptography has been in practice
for centuries Julius Caesar used a
substitution shift to move alphabets a
certain number of spaces beyond their
place in the alphabet table a spy can't
decipher the original message at first
glance for example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use a substitution shift
of plus two a becomes c b becomes D and
so on the word at attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus
three becomes dww dfn this Cipher has
been appropriately named the Caesar
Cipher which is one of the most widely
used
algorithms the Enigma is probably the
most famous cryptographic Cipher device
used in ancient history it was used by
the Nazi German armies in the world wars
they were used to protect confidential
political military and administrative
information and it consisted of three or
more rotors that scrambled the original
message depending on the machine State
at that time the decryption is similar
but it needs both machines to stay in
the same state before passing the cipher
text so that we receive the same plane
text message let's take a look at how
our data is protected while we browse
the internet thanks to cryptography here
we have a web based tool that will help
us understand the process of RSA
encryption we see the entire workflow
from selecting the key size to be used
used until the decryption of the cipher
text in order to get the plain text back
as we already know RSA encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetry key
cryptography that basically implies that
we have two keys at play here a public
key and a private
key typically the public key is used by
the sender to encrypt the message and
the private key is used by the receiver
to decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well in RSA we have the choice of key
size we can select any key from a 512
bit to 1224 bit all the way up to a 496
bit key the longer the key length the
more complex the encryption process
becomes and thereby strengthening the
cipher text although with added security
more complex functions take longer to
perform the same operations on similar
size of data we have to keep a balance
between both speed and strength because
the strongest description algorithms are
of no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024-bit key over here now
we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on past phases the tool we are
using right now generates the pseudo
random keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the cipher
text this pair must be kept together the
public key is then sent to the sender
and the receiver keeps the private key
with himself in this scenario let's try
an encrypt a word simply
learn we have to select if the key being
used for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here
let's select the same and copy it and
paste over
here the cipher we are using right now
is plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well once we click on
encrypt we can see the cipher text being
generated over
here the sudo random generating
functions are created treed in such a
way that a single character change in
the plain text will trigger a completely
different Cipher text this is a security
feature to strengthen the process from
Brute Force methods now that we are done
with the encryption process let's take a
look at the decryption
part the receiver gets this Cipher text
from the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
can be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption
process once we click decrypt you can
see the original plane text we had
decided to encrypt this sums up the
entire process of RSA encryption and
decryption now some people use it the
other way around we also have the option
of using the private key to encrypt
information and the public key to
decrypt it this is done mostly to
validate the origin of the message since
the keys only work in pairs if a
different private key is used to encrypt
the message the public key cannot
decrypt it conversely if the public key
is able to decrypt the message it must
have been encrypted with the right
private key and hence the rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key and use that to encrypt the plain
text and select the same in this
checkbox as well you can see we have
have generated a completely new Cipher
text this Cipher text will be sent to
the receiver and this time we will use
the public key for
decryption let's select the correct
checkbox and decrypt and we still get
the same
output now let's take a look at
practical example of encryption in the
real
world we all use the internet on a daily
basis and many are aware of the
implications of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at Wikipedia here
pretty standard https website where the
H stands for secured let's take a look
at how it secures the
data y shock is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use the software to see the traffic that
is leaving a machine and to understand
how vulnerable it
is since there are many applic ation
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to
[Music]
Wikipedia let's search for something
that we can navigate the website
with okay once we get into it a little
you can see some of the requests being
populated over
here
let's take a look at the specific
request these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice
versa as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way to put this in
perspective let's take a look at another
another website which is a HTTP web
page this has no encryption enabled from
the server end which makes it vulnerable
to attacks there is a login form here
which needs legitimate user credentials
in order to Grant access let's enter a
random pair of
credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data
transfer unsurprisingly we weren't able
to get into the platform instead we can
see the data
packets let's apply a similar filter
that will help us understand what
request this website is
sending
these are the requests being sent by the
HTTP login form to the internet if we
check here see whatever username and
password that we are entering we can
easily see it with the wire shark now we
used a dummy pair of credentials if we
select the right data packet we can find
a correct credentials if any website had
asked for a payment information or a
legitimate credentials it would have
been really easy to get a hold of the
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid HTTP
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online there are two types of
encryption in
cryptography symmetric key
cryptography and asymmetric key
cryptography both of these categories
have their pros and cons and defer only
by the implementation if you want to
become a cyber security expert and gain
handsome salary packages look at a wide
range of cyber security courses offered
by simply learn and that is in
collaboration with top universities
across the globe and a year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses you can find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below and pin comment and make sure to
subscribe to our Channel cyber security
is one of the most in demand and fast
growing fields in the world today as
more and more aspects of Our Lives
depend on digital Technologies the need
to protect them from malicious attacks
also increases but how do you become a
cyber security professional do you need
a degree in cyber security to enter this
field and is it worth the time money and
effort to pursue one the answer to these
questions is not straightforward as
there are many factors to consider when
deciding whether a cyber security degree
is right for you in this video we will
explore some of the pros and cons of
getting a cyber security degree as well
as some alternative paths to consider
but before we begin with this video make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's
understand the growing importance of
cyber
security cyber security is no longer
afterthought for businesses and
organization it's a core component of
their strategies as technology continues
to advance so do the tactics of cyber
criminals from data breaches to
ransomware attacks and identity theft
the consequence of cyber security
threats can be devastating the impact of
these cyber dangers can be very harmful
to prevent these threats companies and
groups must take cyber security
seriously they need to put safeguards in
place to protect their system data and
customers it's not something that can be
overlooked in fact it should be a top
priority a breach in security can lead
to financial losses and damage to a
company's reputation as technology keeps
advancing its crucial for businesses to
keep up with the latest cyber security
practices to stay safe they must be
vigilant and prepared to defend against
cyber threats cyber security is no
longer just a choice it's a necessity
all right so this was about the growing
importance of cyber security in today's
world now let's have a look at some pros
of a cyber security degree the
increasing Reliance on technology the
internet and cloud services means that
more sensitive data is at risk this this
is where cyber Security Professionals
comes into play they are responsible for
safeguarding digital assets protecting
privacy and preventing potential
catastrophes the significance of their
role in today's society cannot be
overstated a cyber security degree can
provide you with many benefits such as a
solid foundation of Technical and
theoretical knowledge a cyber security
degree can teach you the fundamental
concepts principles and techniques of
cyber security such as cryptography
network security malware analysis
digital forensics ethical hacking and
more you can also learn about the legal
ethical and social aspects of cyber
security such as data privacy compliance
and governance next is a Competitive
Edge in the job market yes it provides
you a Competitive Edge in the job market
a cyber security degree can demonstrate
your commitment credibility and
competance to potential employees
according to 2019 report by burning
glass Technologies 88% of cyber security
job of postings requires at least a
bachelor's degree and a cyber security
degree can also help you meet the
eligibility criteria for certain
certifications such as cissp or cism
which can boost your career prospects
and salary potentials all right so the
third one is a wide range of career
options so a degree in cyber security
provides you a wide range of career
options and opportunities a cyber
security degree can open the door to
various rules and sectors in the cyber
security field such as information
security penetration tester security
engineer security consultant cyber
threat intelligent analyst and more you
can also work in different industries
that need cyber Security Professionals
such as Finance Healthcare government
education retail and more next one is
cons of a cyber security degree so let's
have a look at this so a cyber security
degree also has some drawbacks such as
first is a high cost and time commitment
a cyber security degree can be expensive
and time consuming to complete so
depending on the level of type of
degrees you choose associate Bachelors
Masters you may need to spend 2 to six
years of a full-time study and pay tens
of thousands of dollars in the tution
fees you may also need to take out like
student loans or work part-time to
finance your education next one is a
fast changing and dynamic field a cyber
security degree can provide you with the
strong Foundation of Knowledge and
Skills but it may not be enough to keep
up with the ever evolving nature of
cyber security cyber threats are
constantly changing and becoming more
sophisticated while new technologies and
tools are emerging and disrupting the
field you may need to update your skills
and knowledge regularly through
self-learning online courses
certifications or continuing education
programs so now the third one which is a
challenging and stressful work
environment so a cyber security degree
can prepare you for a challenging and
rewarding career but it can also expose
you to a high pressure and demanding
work environment you may need to deal
with tight deadlines heavy workloads
complex systems unpredictable situations
and constant threats you may also face
ethical dilemas legal issues or
emotional stress from dealing with
sensitive data or incidents so this was
about the cons of a cyber security
degree so we have covered pros and cons
of a cyber security degree now next we
will move on to the next topic which is
alternatives to a cyber security
degree so a cyber security degree is not
only a way to enter or Advan in cyber
security field there are some
alternative paths that you can consider
such as boot camps boot camps are
intensive training programs that teach
you the practical skills and tools
needed for a specific rle or domain in
cyber security they usually last from
weeks to a few months and are delivered
online or in person by experts or
instructors they can help you gain
hands-on experience through projects or
simulations and prepare you for the
certifications or job interviews one of
the example is Caltech cyber security
boot camp by simply learn through this
boot camp you will gain all the relevant
skills and a celtech ctme boot camp
certificate so a boot camp basically is
a good alternative to a cyber security
degree for various reasons now coming to
the another alternative of a cyber
security degree that is
certifications so certifications are the
credentials that validate your Knowledge
and Skills in a specific area of topic
of cyber security so they are usually
offered by professional organizations or
vendors and require you to pass an exam
or complete a project they can help you
demonstrate your competence and
credibility to employers or clients and
enhance your career opportunities or
salary potential some examples of this
kind of certifications are the cyber
security Masters program professional
certificate program in cyber security
Advanced executive program in cyber
security
ET so if you are looking to become a
cyber security expert and gain handsome
salary packages then have a look at a
wide range of cyber security courses by
simply learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
programs you will gain expertise in
skills ethical hacking penetration
testing defensive cyber security
cryptography ransomware analysis malware
analysis firewalls network security
vulnerability assessment and much more
so what are you waiting for just hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box so now coming to
the next alternative that is
self-learning yes self-learning is a
process of acquiring new skills and
knowledge on your own using various
resources and methods you can use books
blogs podcast videos online courses or
other materials to learn about cyber
security and the topics related to cyber
security that interest you or are
relevant to your goals you can also use
online platforms tools or labs to
practice your skills and test your
knowledge some examples of self-learning
resources are cybery hack the box or try
hacking so this was about the
alternatives to a cyber security degree
so whether a cyber security degree is
worth it or not depends on your goals a
degree can help you get certain jobs but
there are other ways to succeed like
getting certifications or learning on
your own think about what you want to do
how much money you have and what you
want to learn it's important to keep
learning about cyber security because
it's always changing the value of degree
is about how well it helps you to reach
your goals in the cyber security world
so choose what's best for you based on
what you want to achieve where our lives
are closely connected with technology
cyber security has emerged as very
important concern the ever evolving
landscape of cyber threats requires
professionals who are very well versed
in the Ines of cyber Securities with
2024 fast approaching it's essential to
identify the best cyber security
specializations or certifications s that
will equip you to tackle the challenges
for tomorrow in this video on which
cyber security specialization is best in
2024 we will discuss some best
certifications or specializations that
will pave your way to cyber security
career in this video we will cover why
cyber security specializations are
important after that we will cover
certifications like cissp CompTIA
Security Plus cisa cism SSC CP and C but
before we begin with these
specializations make sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn all right so let's move on
with the first topic that is why cyber
security specializations are important
so cyber security specializations or
certifications are like your digital
armor they are essential because they
teach you how to protect your online
World from the bad guys it's like having
a superp power to keep your information
safe in the world where everything is
connected to the internet like your
phones computers and even your fridge
bad people can try to steal your secrets
these specializations and certifications
are your Shield making you a digital
hero who can stop the villains and keep
your data safe so they are not just
important they are your ticket to
becoming a cyber security superhero so
now let's have a look at the best
specializations of cyber security first
one is certified information system
security professional that is
cisp so the cissp certification is
widely recognized as a premier
certification in the field of
information security it covers a broad
range of topics including security and
risk management asset security security
engineering communication and network
security other topics include security
assessment testing Etc cissp holders
possess a deep understanding of these
domains making them valuable assets in
protecting organizations from cyber
threats the cisp certification is highly
regarded due to its regress requirements
experience prerequisites and adherence
to a code of ethics ensuring
professionals with this certifications
are well-rounded and trustworthy so this
was about cissp now let's have a look at
the next certification so the next
certification is CompTIA Security Plus
so the compa secur plus certification is
an entry-level certification that
provides a solid foundation in cyber
security principles and practices it
covers topics such as network security
threats and vulnerabilities identity
management Access Control cryptography
and risk management this certification
is highly regarded for the vendor
neutral approach making it applicable
across different technology platforms it
is an excellent starting point for
individuals looking to enter the cyber
security field or enhance their
knowledge in information security the
Security Plus certification is
recognized globally and is often a
prerequisite for more advanced
certification making it a valuable
stepping stone in one's cyber security
career also if you want to become a
cyber Security Professionals then
consider Advanced executive program in
cyber security by simply learn this
Advanced executive program in cyber
security will help you develop expertise
in defensive cyber security application
security malware analysis ethical
hacking Etc in partnership with triple
ID Bangalore and npci the cyber security
program provides you with a deep
understanding needed to spot the
opportunities for disruption in the
cyber security industry so what are you
waiting for and roll now get certified
and get ahead so this was about the coma
Security Plus certification next best
certification on the list is certified
information system auditor that is cisa
the cisa certification is specially
designed for professional involved in
auditing controlling and monitoring
Information Systems it focuses on
accessing vulnerabilities and ensuring
compliance with regularity standards
cisa holders possess expertise in
auditing processes it governance systems
and infrastructure life cycle management
and information systems this
certification is highly regarded for its
emphasis on risk management and its
alignment with International auditing
standards CIS certified professionals
are in high demand as they provide
Assurance to organizations that their
information systems are secure reliable
and compliant so this was about cisa
that is certified information system
auditor now coming to the next
certification which is cism that is
certified information security manager
so the cism is tailored certification
for professionals responsible for
managing designing and overseeing and
Enterprise information security program
it covers four domains information
security governance risk management
information security program development
and management and information security
Incident Management cism holders possess
a comprehensive understanding of these
domains enabling them to align
information security with businesses
goals and objectives effectively this
certification is highly regarded that
its focus on strategic management and
its emphasis on the relationship between
information security and business
success cism certified professionals are
sought after for their ability to
establish and manage an organization's
information security program effectively
so this was about cism certification now
let's have a look at the next
certification which is sscp system
security certified practitioner the scsp
certification is designed for
professionals involved in the the
Hands-On implementation and operation of
information security systems it covers
topics such as access controls security
operations and administration risk
identification and mitigation incident
response and
cryptography scsp holders possess
practical Knowledge and Skills in
various areas of information security
making them valuable Assets in
implementing and maintaining security
systems this certification is highly
regarded for its emphasis on technical
expertise and its alignment with
industry best practices SSP certified
professionals are sought after for their
ability to apply security controls and
counter measures to protect
organizations from evolving threats so
this was about sscp now the next
certification is C that is certified
ethical hacker so the certified ethical
hacker certification offered by EC
council is a highly respected
certification in the field of cyber
security it focuses on training
individuals to think and act like
malicious hackers to identify
vulnerabilities and weaknesses the CES
certification covers topics such as
footprinting and scanning networks
enumeration system hacking malware
threats social engineering and more this
certification equips professionals with
the skills and knowledge needed to
access and strengthen an organization
security posture with its emphasis on
ethical hacking the C certification
plays a crucial role in helping
organizations proactively defend against
cyber threats and Safeguard their
critical
assets so if you want to prepare for all
these specializations then you can opt
for simply learns cyber security expert
Masters program the cyber security
expert Masters program will equip you
with the skills needed to become an
expert in the rapidly growing domain you
will learn comprehensive approaches to
protecting your infrastructure including
securing data and information running
risk analysis and mitigation
architecturing cloud-based security
achieving compliance and much more with
this best-in-class program this
certification will equip you with the
skills that entail industry-leading
certifications like CompTIA Security
Plus C cism cissp and
ccsp and roll now the link is in the
description
box so the certifications that we have
covered in this video are considered the
best due to the comprehensive coverage
of essential cyber security domains
their recognition in industry and their
alignment with industry standards and
best practices they provide
professionals with the knowledge skills
credibility needed to excel in the field
of information security and contribute
to the protection of organizations from
cyber threats today we have an
incredibly important topic to discuss
especially in this day and age where
online threats are constantly evolving
we are diving deep into the world of
cyber security and we will be talking
about the top cyber security tools for
2024 so whether you are individual
concerned about your Online safety or a
business looking to protect your digital
assets you are in the right place so
let's get started and before starting if
you are an aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
Lear postgraduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
a right choice this course is designed
to accommodate a diverse range of
Learners and this course requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% average and
no prior programming experience and
OnePlus year of work experience is
preferred for more details you can use
the link in the description box below
now let's get started with the
increasing Reliance on digital
Technologies our privacy and safety are
at risk more than ever before cyber
security tools play a vital role in
protecting us from potential online
threats so we'll start with objectives
of cyber security tools so cyber
security tools have various objectives
and they're designed the first is to
analyze infrastructure data to detect
anomalies and vulnerabilities and the
next objective is to automate cyber
security workflows for efficiency and
then we have build secure webbased
services and then monitor network
operations and user activities so these
are the objectives of cyber security
tools now we'll see the considerations
for choosing cyber security tools
choosing the right cyber security tools
for your specific needs is crucial here
are some key considerations When
selecting these tools number one is
scalability Ure the tool can protect
many endpoints and devices across a wide
parameter and then we have integration
it should seamlessly integrate with your
existing systems and the next
consideration is opt for tools with
reliable support at cyber SECU is ever
evolving and the next consideration is
purpose built look for tools designed to
address different scenarios effectively
and the next is compatibility the tool
should work with various device variants
operating systems and Cloud vendors so
these are the considerations for
choosing cyber security tool now let's
dive into the exciting part that is the
top service security tools for 2024 so
these tools are designed to keep you
safe in the the digital world so first
we will start with solar wind security
event manager the solar wind security
event manager is a powerful network
monitoring platform with realtime packet
analysis capabilities and dynamic
baselines to detect genuine performance
deviations and now we'll see the key
features for the solar wind security
event manager so the first key feature
is smarter scalability solar wind
security event manager offers scalable
Solutions suitable for large
environments whether your organization
has numerous endpoints or diverse
devices spread across a wide parameter
this tool can adapt and protect your
network effectively then we have multi-
wender network monitoring this feature
allows you to monitor not only your
network but also a variety of vendors
ensuring that you can keep an eye on all
aspects of your digital infrastructure
this is essential in today's
interconnected and multivendor network
environments and then we have advanced
alerting system solar wind security
event manager provides an advanced
alerting system that helps you detect
and respond to security threats swiftly
by setting up customized alerts you can
proactively address potential issues
before they escalate into major Bridges
and then we have monitor end to end
Network understanding the entire network
path is crucial for identifying botal
necks vulnerabilities and potential
threats solar winds tool enables you to
Monitor and to and network Parts
ensuring that you have full visibility
into your network performance and the
next key feature is cross tech network
data correlation with cross tech network
data correlation you can connect the
dots between various Network elements
and pinpoint the root cause of issues
quickly this capability is a game
changer when it comes to troubleshooting
and responding to security incidents so
this was all about the first tool that
is solar wind security event manager now
moving to second tool tool that is wire
shock it's an open-source Network
protocol analyzer that helps
professionals identify network security
weaknesses by capturing and analyzing
data packets in real time now we'll see
the key features of wire shock so the
first key feature is crossplatform
compatibility wi shock is a
crossplatform tool which means it can be
installed on a variety of operating
systems making it accessible to a wide
range of users then we have open source
architecture being open source means
that wire shock is continually improved
by a global community of developers this
openness also facilitates easy
integration with other cyber security
tools and systems and then the next
feature is realtime data capture and
Analysis v shark provides real-time
packet capture and Analysis allowing you
to monitor network activity as it
happens this feature is invaluable for
identifying anomalies security threats
and performance issues
and then the next feature is decryption
protocol support it supports decryption
for multiple Network protocols and
various output formats enabling you to
understand encrypted traffic and
identify potential security
vulnerabilities and now moving to the
next tool that is the third tool and
that is ax script so ax script premium
offers Advanced encryption features in a
userfriendly package ensuring your data
remains secure
it supports various platforms making it
convenient for users and now we'll see
the key features of ax script the number
one is 256bit encryption a script
employs strong 256bit encryption which
is virtually unbreakable with current
technology this level of encryption
ensures that your data remains secure
and confidential and the next is
userfriendly interface one of EX
script's standout feature is its user
friendly interface encrypting and
recting files is as simple as dragging
and dropping them into the a script
window this accessibility makes it
usable for users and all technical
levels and the next is secure file
deletion a excript goes beyond
encryption by offering secure file
deletion this feature ensures that when
you delete an encrypted file it becomes
virtually impossible to recover
providing an additional layer of data
protection and then the next feature is
gross platform compatibility a script
supports various operating systems
including Windows Mac OS Android and iOS
this versatility allows you to encrypt
and decrypt files seamlessly across
different devices and platforms and then
the next feature is user support a
script provides user support through
email forums and even second level
support while chat if you encounter any
issues or have questions about using the
tool there's a support system in place
to assist you and then the next feature
is public key cryptography a script
offers the option to use public key
cryptography which allows you to
securely share encrypted files with
others only those with the appropriate
decryption key can access the files
enhancing collaboration while
maintaining security so why excript
matters data protection a script is a
crucial tool for safeguarding sensitive
data whether you are an individual
protecting personal files or a business
securing confidential documents a script
ensures that your information remains
private and now moving on to the fourth
tool that is Kali Linux kalii Linux is a
widely used cyber security tool with
over 300 utilities for scanning Network
systems it's a gr for both experts and
entry-level professionals making it
versatile and effective and now moving
to key features for Cali Linux the
number one feature is versatile tool set
K linu boast an extensive collection of
over 300 cyber security tools making it
incredibly versatile for various tasks
including network analysis vulnerability
assessment and penetration testing and
then we have userfriendly interface
despite its powerful capabilities Kali
Linux offers a userfriendly interface
making it accessible even to those with
limited Linux experience it Manu Dam
navigation implify and simplifies the
process of selecting and using tools and
the next is customizable Ki Linux allows
users to customize and tailor the
distribution to their specific needs
this means you can install additional
tools or remove unnecessary ones to
create streamline and efficient
environment and then we have regular
updates to stay ahead of emerging
threats and vulnerabilities kalii Linux
is continuously updated the development
team ensures that the tools within the
distribution are up to date with the
latest security patches and Improvement
M ments and then we have wide device
compatibility Ki Linux is compatible
with a wide range of hardware and can be
installed on various devices including
laptops desktops and even Raspberry Pi
devices this flexibility ensures that
you can take your cyber security toolkit
with you wherever you go and the next we
have is Community Support Ki Linux has a
vibrant and active community of users
and developers who contribute to its
growth and provide support through
forums this Community aspect makes it
easier to learn and troubleshoot any
issues you may encounter now moving to
the fifth tool that is air crack NG air
crack NG is an open- Source suit of
Wireless tools used for analyzing Wi-Fi
network security weaknesses it's a
comprehensive Solution that's entirely
free now we'll see and learn some of the
key features of air crack NG the first
feature is open source architecture
aircrack NG is a open source software
which means it's freely available for
anyone to use modify and contribute to
its development this open Nature Fosters
a community of users and developers
continuously working to enhance its
capabilities and the next is
compatibility aircra NG is versatile in
terms of compatibility while it
primarily works on Linux it has also
been adapted to run on other operating
systems including Windows Mac OS free
bstd open bstd net bstd Solaris and even
Ecom Station 2 this compatibility
ensures that users from various
backgrounds and preferences can harness
its power now the next feature is suit
of programs airra NG comprises a suit of
programs each serving a specific purpose
in wireless network security some of the
notable components include air Decap NG
aerod dump NG air T and NG so these
command line tools allow for intricate
scripting and customization making air
crack NG a valuable asset for
professionals seeking to fine-tune their
wireless security efforts and the next
feature is Wi-Fi security assessment
aircrack NG is particularly adapt at
assessing the security of Wi-Fi networks
and the next is password cracking one of
the standout features of aircrack ngj is
is its ability to crack Wi-Fi passwords
while it's essential to use its
capability responsibly and legally the
next is Community Support airc NG boast
an active and engaged user community so
this was the features of aircrack now
moving on to the tool six that is ncto
so ncto is an excellent open- source
tool focused on scanning the web for
vulnerabilities covering both web
servers and networks it's continuously
updated to help users identify threats
now moving on to see the key features of
ncto number one is comprehensive
scanning ncto database consists of
approximately 6,400 distinct types of
security threats covering both web
servers and networks it scans websites
for a wide range of vulnerabilities
including outdated software
misconfigured servers and known security
issues the next feature is web server
and network focus nto is specialized in
scrutinizing web servers and the
networks St operator it doesn't just
look for issues on the surface it digs
deep into the servers configuration to
identify potential weaknesses the next
is continuous updates the the tool is
continuously updated to keep Pace with
emerging threats and vulnerabilities the
next is lightweight and versatile ncto
is a lightweight web application
vulnerability scanner making it easy to
use and integrate into existing security
workflows the next is plug-in system
ncto plug-in system allows for easy
extensibility new plugins can be created
to make it compatible with different
systems making it adaptable to a wide
variety of web server setups so how ncto
works nto operates by sending HTTP
request to the Target web server and
analyzing the responses it receives it
looks for specific patterns or
characteristics that indicate
vulnerabilities nto doesn't exploit
vulnerabilities but rather provides a
comprehensive report highlighting
potential issues allowing administrators
to take appropriate action so this was
all about the ncto tool now moving to
the seventh tool that is force point
force point is a tool used to customize
sdon helping track and prevent malicious
activities within networks it offers a
high level of customization and
real-time content analysis now going to
see the key features of this tool the
number one is high level security Force
Point provides a high level of security
across various applications and
resources within your network the next
is seamless integration the tool
seamlessly integrates with different
network components ensuring that it
doesn't disrupt your existing
infrastructure and the next is
customization one of the standout
feature of force point is is its
customization capabilities users can
tailor policies fingerprints and
classifiers to meet their specific
security requirements the next is
realtime content analysis Force Point
offers real-time content analysis and
classification this means that it can
identify and classify content flowing
through your network in real time the
next is gross portfolio intelligence
Force Point leverages cross portfolio
and third party Global share threat
intelligence networks this means that it
has access to a vast pool of thread data
making it more effective in identifying
and mitigating emerging threats so this
was all about the force Point tool now
moving on to the eighth tool that is
nessus professional tool nessus
professional is a handy vulnerability
scanner that's updated daily with new
thread data it's an essential tool for
improving Network Integrity now we'll
see the key features of this tool the
number one is remote scanning tool
nessus professional is is a remote
scanning tool that excels in high-speed
asset Discovery the next is daily thread
data updates one of the standout
features of ness's professional is its
commitment to staying up to date with
the everchanging threat landscape and
the next is ease of deployment and use
unlike some complex cyber security tools
nessus professional is known for its
ease of deployment and user friendliness
and the next is support from 10bl expert
vulnerability research team with ness's
professional you are not just getting a
software tool you are gaining access to
the expertise of table's vulnerability
research team this ensures that you have
top r support and access to the latest
insights into the cyber security
landscape and the next feature is gross
platform compatibility nessus
professional is compatible with various
operating systems including Mac Linux
and windows this broad compatibility
makes it accessible for a wide range of
users and organizations and this was all
for this tutorial picture an employer at
her computer working with data in a
background a hacker secretly access her
company's or his company's confidential
files he or she steals sensitive
information and sells it to criminals
who then hold the company ransom for a
profit it sound like something out a
movie but unfortunately it's a common
occurrence in today's online landscape
this is why cyber security has become
such a vital part of any business
strategy and cyber security specialist
are in demand now more than ever let me
share you some fascinating stategic with
you that illustrate the impact and
potential of cyber security before we
delve into the fascinating cyber world
according to glasso the average salary
of a cyber security engineer is $113,000
in the US and in India it's 7 lakh
perom learning AI offers numerous
benefits ranging from career
opportunities and Innovations to
personal growth and ethical
consideration it equips with your
valuable skills and knowledge that can
have a profound impact on a various
aspect of society and the World At Large
but choosing the right course to excel
in the field of cyber security can be
challenging with so many option
available out there in the market how do
you know which one is the right for you
well we are here to help you without any
further Ado let's discuss the top five
cyber security certification for 2024
number one on the list is postgraduate
program in cyber security in collab
cation with MIT University this
postgraduate program in cyber security
is designed to keep with the skills
required to become an expert in the
rapidly growing field of cyber security
the Cyber Security Programs aims to help
you stay ahead of all the latest Trend
in the cyber security as well this
course will help you learn comprehensive
approaches to protecting your
infrastructure and securing data
including risk analysis mitigation and
compliance you will get foundational to
advance skills through industry leading
cyber security certification courses in
the program this poed program in cyber
security includes cyber security
technology application and policy from
mitc this program leverages mit's
academic excellence in cyber security
and provides comprehensive understanding
of the field to ensure your Readiness
for the industry you will also engage in
multiple projects allowing you to hor
your skills and emerge as an exceptional
cyber security professional for
admission to this postgraduate program
in cyber security candidate should have
a bachelor degree with an average of 50%
or higher grades have a non programming
background not required to have a prior
Works experience so join now seats are
feeling fast the course link is in the
description box below number two on the
list is triple it Bangalore Advanced
executive program in cyber security
become an industry ready professional
with an advanced executive program in
cyber security and transform your career
in six month this course provides a high
engagement learning experience
experience with real word application
and is designed for individuals who want
to start a new more fulfilling career
this Advanced executive program in cyber
security will help you develop expertise
in defensive cyber security application
security malware analysis ethical
hacking and many others in partnership
with triple it Bangalore and npci the
cyber security program provide you with
a deep understanding of needed to sport
the opportunity for disruption in cyber
security industry after completing the
course learn Learners have made
successful career transition boosted
career growth and got average healthy
cycle of 70% and maximum salary hike of
150% so why to join this program so why
triple it Bangalore Advantage virtual
internship with npci integrated Labs
career mentorship for admission to this
postgraduate program in cyber security
candidate should have a bachelor degree
with an average 50% or higher grades
have a non-programming background are
not required to have private work
experience so join now seats are filling
fast the course link is in the
description box below number third on
the list is cyber security expert master
program the cyber security expert master
program will equip with the skills
needed to become an expert in this
rapidly growing domain you will learn
comprehensive approaches to protecting
your infrastructure including securing
data and information running risk
analysis and mitigation architecting
cloud-based security achieving
compliance and much more with this Best
in Class program simply learn cyber
security expert master program provides
cyber security professional with
foundational level intermediate level
and advanced level skills that entail
industry leading certification like com
Tia Security Plus C cism
cissp and ccsp the program begins with
industry level technology training then
progresses to intermediate level hacking
techniques such as reverse engineering
and network penetration testing this
course will enable you to stay up to
date with the latest cyber security news
and Trends and then make sure are
implementing edicate cyber security
measures in your organization using
suitable hardware and software so join
now seats are filling fast the course
link is in the description box below
number fourth on the list is IIT kpur
professional certificate program in
cyber security red team boost your
career as a cyber security expert
throughout this cyber security program
in collaboration with IIT canut in just
6 months you will learn Advanced
offensive cyber security strategies to
protect networks and data from breaches
theft attacks and more professional
certificate program in cyber security
red team empowers you with a skill set
to analyze the thread landscape and
create strategies to ensure system
stability and security Master essential
cyber security skills through Hands-On
training in real world cases simply
learns professional certificate program
and cyber security red team leverages it
kpur academic excellence in cyber
security and equip with students with
key skills through a unique applied
learning approach this programs provide
you with the necessary skills to
leverage offensive cyber security to
strengthen the stability and security of
it system you will benefit from and be
better able to master the highly sought
after cyber security capabilities owning
to the comprehensive curriculum of the
program to gain admission to this
program candidate should have a bachelor
degree in a related field basic
knowledge of programming and sabit
security two plus years of work
experience prer so join now seats are
feeling fast the course link is in the
description box below the last one on
the list is C V12 certified ethical
hacking course learning Advanced
processes in ch certified ethical
hacking course in this online ethical
hacking certification training you will
have Master Advanced Network packet
analysis and system penetration testing
techniques to build your network
security skill set and prevent hackers
you will get access to to certified
expert professional who will guide you
throughout your Learning Journey simply
learn CES certification course provides
the hands-on experience required to
master the techniques hackers leverage
to penetrate Network system and fortify
your against it this certificed ethical
hacking course is aligned with the
latest C v12 by the e Council and with
adequately prepare you to scale your
skills this ethical hacking
certification verifies the skills
required to thrive in information
security domain
many it departments have made CH
compulsory for security related post CS
certified ethical hacker professional on
44% higher salaries than non-certified
profession this ethical hacking
Certification need learner need to
possess an undergraduate degree or a
high school diploma in any discipline as
may be prevalent and accepted in their
respective country of residence and or
work so join now seats are filling first
the course link is in the description
box below imagine a digital real where
Brave companies are guardians of Online
safety these companies have the most
excellent tools and tricks to protect us
from sneaky hackers and all sorts of
digital baddies in this video we'll
introduce you to the top 10 superheroes
of the cyber security World these
companies are like the Avengers of the
internet but instead of capes they wear
the lines of code they have got
high-tech gadgets super smart experts
and a mission to keep our Digital World
safe we'll introduce a few organizations
that stand in Paramount in the fight
against digital threats with their
best-in-class teams and a few more
spearhead to Shield the confidential
information through their robers tactics
let me share some fascinating statistics
with you that illustrate the impact and
potential of cyber security before we
delve into the fascinating cyber world
according to glaso the average salary of
a cyber security engineer is
$130,000 in the United States and rupes
7 lakh perm in India so get ready to
meet the Cyber Shield wielding champion
who are stopping the hackers in their
tracks and making sure your online world
is as safe as it can it's time to dive
into the world of cyber security
superheroes so welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel today we bring you the
list of the exact top 10 organizations
that are the Titans of the cyber
security World in 2024 before we get
started if these are the type of videos
you would like to watch then hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
get notified whenever we drop a new
video this postgraduate program in cyber
security will help you learn
comprehensive approaches to protecting
your infrastructure and securing data
including risk analysis mitigation and
compliance you'll get foundational to
advance skills through industry leading
cyber security certification courses in
this program for admission to this
post-graduate program in cyber security
candidate should have a bachelor's
degree with an average of 50% or higher
marks candidates may have a
non-programming background and
candidates with one plus year of work
experience are preferred for this this
program so join now seats are filling
fast the course link is mentioned in the
description box below so without any
further delay let's send over this
session to our training expert so these
are the top 10 cyber security companies
for
2024 so moving forward we will see these
companies about these companies one by
one PTO Network 4et crowd strike mafe
OCTA IBM AA Cisco Microsoft Services
checkpoint so moving forward let's start
with P Alto Network founded in 2005 PTO
network is a leading Global cyber
security company with over 54,000
customers in approximately 1 15
countries their platform automate
security task using analytics
simplifying protection for the users
data and application they offer cyber
security solution to various Industries
like manufacturing Finance retail
healthc care and O and gas and many more
other covering Network cloud and mobile
devices in private SAS and public Cloud
environment poo elto Network provides
Advanced firewall endpoint protection
Cloud security thread detection and
prevention notably their cloud-based
security products and advanced Fireballs
are trusted by over 85 Fortune 100
companies and 63% of the global 2000
moving forward next we let's see the 40
net 4et network security provider is not
averse to rigorous testing earning its
placement on set second of the our forat
list for cyber security software and
Hardware despite achieving sales
exceeding 4 billion cyber analysts
anticipate a robust 35% of annual growth
rate over next 5 years 148 Xcel its core
network security domain and exhibit
significant progress in other critical
security areas like
s and EDR foret has leveraged its
networking expertise to assume
leadership roles in related markets such
as
sdw software defined wide area network
the companies enjoy High customer
satisfaction ratings particularly in
aspect like product capabilities value
ease of use and support which have
enabled it to penetrate a small business
Market as well anest have also commended
foret frequenty featuring in alongside p
elto and other in prominent posting in
Gartner magic quadens and Forester WAP
reports moving forward let's see crowd
strike the crowd strike Falcon presents
an integrated platform that effectively
tackles critical security issues such as
threat intelligence it security and
Cloud protection moreover it comes fully
equipped with extended detection and
response xdr capabilities to provide
comprehensive defense against threat
through xdr crowd strike has the
capability to gather and analyze crowd
strike has the capability to gather and
analyze data across networks Cloud
environments and various platform
enabling a deep understanding of threat
levels and the early detection of
anomalies before they result in IR
reversible harm so next on the list is
aast founded in 1988 aast has gained
prominence as a notable provider of
cyber security solution the company
boast a growing patent portfolio
encompassing location Technologies
machine learning artificial intelligence
malare detection and prevention and iot
Internet of Things Technologies a also
take pride in its extensive range of
thread protection product designed for
the businesses including its highly
sought after Cloud care solution it's
worth nothing that cloud care solution
offers both Network and endpoint
security while aest offers free
antivirus software it's essential to
remark that it may not defect all the
types of malware the free version
provides essential real-time protection
which proves valuable especially if you
have a family members who tend to click
on every download now
so moving forward let's see
mcafe mcafe with its effective security
solution offers production against
potential risk these Services
encompasses all aspect of your company
asset including mobile devices and
subsidi crowds resources for instance
mcafe has established a partnership with
the prominent technology solution
providers zero to address the security
concern of their customer through this
collaboration the technology giant has
introduced connect
technology intending with mcfa to ensure
secure data transmission to and from
their cities this encription
capabilities empowers users to
concentrate on innovating their products
without the burden of security Bridge
concern moving next let's see OCTA OCTA
aims to break away from the conventional
Network Premier security model and
instead provides integrated solution for
countering threats across various
platform with OA support you can
effectively oversee potential threats
while safeguarding both your
organization on premises networks and
Cloud infrastructure Oka employs a
programmatic approach to deliver
automated response to threats when
combined with addictive multiactor
authentication this platform establish a
robust layer of security around all your
assets so next on the list is checkpoint
checkpoint provides a distinctive
approach to cyber security solution
through a multi tired architecture known
as Infinity designed to bolster
production additionally it is equipped
with Advanced GN V threat prevention
capabilities to safeguard data within
the cloud and on remote devices such as
mobiles what sets organization apart its
dedicated intelligence complemented by
an incident response team that specify
in data driven services with features
like thread hunting and tabletop
exercises it ensure comprehensive
protection for all interconnected
systems so next on the list is Cisco
Cisco stand out as one of the rapidly
expanding cyber Security Solutions
providers in the market the company
distinguish itself through its adaptable
offering highlighted by the feature
known as secure remote work these
components render this package ideally
suited for evolving landscape of remote
work models so number one is global
access to web apps meetings and
messaging second is distinct identify
verification for user devices and
application the third is robust umbrella
security to combat a wide area of
threats the fourth one is email security
measures to edicate malware and Virus
Infection Cisco also delivers continuous
updates and leverages threat
intelligence to streamline the security
process you can invest in versatile
solution like Cloud endpoint and
firewall security so next on the list is
Microsoft Services another prominent
entry on the roster is Microsoft a
technology giant headquartered in
Washington Microsoft is dedicated to
providing cyber security solution that
align with your strategic goals much
like IBM it employs a structured
approach to identify and mitigate risk
this methodology encompasses stages such
as first one is evaluating the risk
level the second is conducting a dynamic
identify framework assessment the third
is implementing measures to secure
against lateral account movement the
fourth one is ensuring rapid response
and Recovery in the event of incidents
businesses have warmly emise this brand
considering Microsoft claim of
surpassing the 10 billion threshold in
Security Services Revenue alone in just
one year the security industry experien
a remarkable 40% growth so next on the
list is IBM cyber security services IBM
are technology B bot ranks among the
leading companies offering a
comprehensive area of cyber security
services tailored to your company's
requirement the organization asserts its
capability to assess a mitigate risk
through the four distinct method the
first one is identification in this
phase the objective is to divers a
strategy for managing and reducing risk
that impact critical element like people
data and system the second one is
protection emphasizing digital
transformation IBM fortify every
corporate asset and reduce resources
through a zero trust approach the third
one is detection the Enterprise
leverages artificial intelligence to
proactively respond to emerging risk and
assesses potential threats based on
historical data the fourth one is
response to expedite the response time
and minimize system risk IBM offers
Round the Clock incident response
Services these are the cyber security
companies to which you can apply for the
cyber security jobs being cyber security
analyst cyber security engineer risk
analyst and enjoy the handsome package
or
Salary thank you for watching today's
video on cyber security for beginners I
hope you find it informative and helpful
in your journey to enhance your online
security remember knowledge is the first
step in protecting yourself only online
if you have any questions or want to
explore more about cice Security check
out our other videos on this topic and
don't forget to subscribe for more
content to keep you updated and informed
about the Ever Changing world of cyber
security stay safe out there in the
digital realm and I will see you in the
next video don't forget to like share
and subscribe for more exciting content
see you next time and stay secure
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts ch use any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here